une production du studio sfr venez au
sans fil très le podcast on parle de ce
qu'on veut nous inviter dati se perchent
quand on est encore une fois pas avec
moi cette semaine d'une plante domi et à
québec pour pour faire mamma mia en ce
moment il fait les traces a commise
musical je pense au grand théâtre
si vous êtes à québec aller voir ma
mamie heures puis la guide que vous
entendez mcdoom qui joue fait qu'on a
fait un petit peu de gymnastique dans
notre dans la façon qu'ont fait nos
podcasts fait que souvent ça de moins
dans les prochaines semaines qui fait
naître au dessus parce que l'intro des
fois et décalée du podcast en tout cas
peu importe la logistique vous avez pas
besoin de vous inquiéter que tout va
bien
écoutez cette semaine c'est c'est ultra
s'émouvant sinotte un an du sans filtre
podcast on a décidé de vous faire un
petit montage best of c'est nicholl
nicholl cousue sûrement vu passer dans
le podcast de l'étendre nicole décidé de
nous faire un petit montage best-of fait
que on va vous mettre ça cette semaine
pour célébrer notre un an plus de 2.5
millions d' écoute à travers toutes les
plateformes plus de 25 mille abonnés sur
youtube
cinquante deux épisodes vus depuis j'ai
dit j'ai des frissons c'est fou on
pourrait pas faire le sans filtre sans
vous on pourrait pas continuer à faire
ce ce qui a commencé comme un projet un
peu coup de tête dans ma cuisine est
rendue dans un studio le studio sf qu'on
est super bien installé produits
d'autres podcast elle a vraiment pris
une ampleur démesurée puis inattendue en
a deux un an puis tout le crédit
revient à vous un peu tout le crédit
c'est sûr qu'un petit peu de crédit qui
revient à nous la met la plupart du
crédit revient à vous parce qu'il
suffisait pologne nous on pourrait pas
faire se fait sans plus attendre
profitez de ce best-of première
anniversaire de sans filtre podcast
bonne écoute et bon broadcast
[Musique]
joe rogan et avait déjà dit rich aucoin
podcasteurs vegan et avait déjà dit
qu'ils sentaient joe rogan sentait qu'il
y avait plus en commun que les vegan que
le monde qui mangent leur viande qui
serait au sens où ils mangent italien
que lui tu es il refusait complètement
le l'industrie de la viande est
complètement tout seul c'est juste parce
que ils respectent et rôle et l'animal
comme tel puis je pensais à penser à
évoluer ce qui sait si c'est ça qui est
cool lecture logan déjà pensé évolué au
fil d'un petit il pas fermé d'esprit par
rapport à rien ouais ben c'est un
mandant dans le temps je m'en rappelle
même salle le vraiment aidé son humour
je me rappelle de rogun faisait du stand
d'objets des années 90 début 2000 points
je trouvais ça ordinaire
la prestation magna qui me l'avait fait
écouter j'en mets ton mi 2010 était déjà
je le trouvais meilleur pilote depuis ne
sont pas qu'à ça sérieusement lui dans
la conversation avec du monde que tu
montes brillant fille apprend tellement
d'affaires
je trouve ça l'est vraiment pour son
humour et son dernier special je pense à
cette lettre a girl way était vraiment
bon vous savez pas capoter à ce titre je
trouvais le thème était bon mais je
trouve que ça des lévriers andré qui dit
il
cricri 1 et c'en est un il est très mâle
alpha mos annonce
c'était moi je l'avais vu une fois quand
il termine à montréal son fan boys à
l'époque c'était avant sont pas gâtés
que 10 des gens de gabat si fan du fc
tout le monde et des chandails tapas le
pilote à mener avec joe wright a
apparemment donné il y avait une fille à
la vecquerie est quoi jeter un clarté
d'aptitude à la région sauvegarder avait
dit chad ap stupide ailleurs le yang a
fait ait pas cool parler de my man femme
qui l'oeil avait glacé copie des statuts
d igor qui font du mm x enfin l'outil
que dans leurs têtes sont capables
d'abattre kg stade relevant tout dgac
avait pas de lui
keystone en prison y arrivera quelque
part pis c'est lui qui rendent la place
exactement les twittos capitale il
s'était il y avait peut-être senti ce
genre de rapport le qui essayait d'être
reçus d un peu un propos un peu mais moi
quand je rencontre le mans bush très
jack jack jones by et super sérieux tout
ça moi je pense moi je les déstabiliser
qu'il lui mode déstabiliser qui c'est la
deuxième fois que je le rencontrais la
première fois c'était fort que nous il
est trés haut comme l'histoire - il
m'avait écrit sur
sur twitter je vais envoyer quelque
chose en 10ème surtout été là il m'avait
écrit à ce titre j'aimerais savoir à mon
pote gaz
c'est quand la prochaine fois tu viens
et les six mois je vois jamais allé je
me sens bien à toi j'ai regardé mon
horaire que j'ai fait et shiloh du 6 au
8 j'ai pas eu triche peu à être là
dessus mais j'ai fait choix du 6 au 8
mars maintenant le géant voisin kg il me
répond pas au point la cloche fait asti
par la crise mais je me moque un débit
est un des billets d'avion kogovsek là
je me suis booké des billets d'avion
chemin sous louer une maison labo dallas
et les voir mon seul ami l'autriche est
passé la semaine au pyla niro guen pige
à l'époque de ces je voulais pas leader
s'est caché commencé grâce à quelqu'un
un stick 2 c'est pas mal aussi je le
sais tu es maintenant quelqu'un qui me
fait la demande que je veux avant ça se
peut que ça prenne des fois un mot 6
mois 1 an qui sport à mon gars à tous et
je vais te remonter ou de la liste de
votre avis mais je vous l'avais dit à
tout le monde et je me disais je vais
aller témoigner quand tu vois et les la
plage à maxou cadre historique il ya
comme une terrasse salle à l'ambiance du
festival du mot passe c'est juste des
humoristes tout le monde se tait j'ai
l'impression
robin est tout le temps là sur mon vélo
qui est quoi que j'aime de dudu comme
les freins tout sens comme site et aux
seconds à avec moche marc abel les
premières fois que j allais jeter comme
le petit cul de 6e année qui allait dans
les parties de seconde en secondaire 1
tu es comme le gôpô coule pas prêt d
année en année que ty par des contacts
pas des trucs chanter qu'à aucun moment
un statut pilot tesco crise le champ du
commun secondaires trop qui aussitôt que
mettons un développeur la rive se
réalise onewest en seconde à retrouve
lui et à lui verser
le monde qui me lécher le cul il y avait
une note alice de moelle avec apple
vient de rentrer dans la ce qui me
ferait tout le temps le pilote ayant
amené mon chat mindy fait écrit sur
rogen rogen et seule chose est sur scène
il va débarquer vous réveille parler
pour qui de voir quelle était ta et les
jets fataki parfait je voyais les pilot
je m'étais encore le domaine de ma vie
est en train de parler à quelqu'un
d'autre
kg j'avais pas vu le facteur subit pas
pire sociale quand betty jusqu'à règles
sociales a jamais dit de me 3,20 dans le
corre sus à l'aise actuellement mais
agen à agen si j'avais de la nano cible
ou et donc je ça arrive et clust com
ahidjo qui leur est commun et puis très
froid puis je fais à chaque fois les
faits arguant le fait que 10 à long
terme forfait
je pars mercredi arrêts et sûrement pas
la cible à stx et whiplash love aux
toilettes vous parlez à côté des
toilettes ou comment cette cyclo
j'entends rogan faire attaquer mais il
parlait pas de moins mais moi j'y pense
il parlait de lui comme à tabanac il a
le chanteur robin thicke homme
fantastique c'est l'eau après je
l'entendis t il jusqu'à pas bhl fait
rire quand la salle c'est juste des noms
en silence dans la salle personne ne rit
plus comme s'appellent par les bonnes -
il parlait genre de nom mais il parlait
de gens là ces soins jamie foxx ou 1,6
me parler de lui la conversation avant
cette crise du nord après le carton et
que j'avais faite a créé je pense je
pense pour de vrai sur le coup j'ai fait
j'avais tellement fort que la courbe que
ce jeune phoque et méchant j'irai plus
génération avec rogen qui va se jouer de
la façon je me suis fait bouquet sur
rogen mois à chaque fois que je faisais
à chaque fois que j'ai fait un road trip
20 dernières années
montréal floride robin ça donnait tout
le temps qu'ils parlaient de moins
pendant que j'ai dans mon chat a aucun
texte ne soit pas car ça lui n'ont même
pas c'est que le monde le texte passe
moi j écoute jamais la belgique est
effectué et que plein de textos
la première fois j'avais reçues j'avais
j'écoutais plein de podcasts là je
recevais plein de textes de femmes
croisées christ 30 enduro guen a parlé
de tout cela
franche à la deuxième fois il y en avait
qui en avait parlé
je tends carlan chars direction florine
lots cette fois ci j'étais en train de
tracter mes enfants dans mon monteur
basse pour descendre en floride puis
je reçois un appel de mentalist le
podcast avec mon anglais et comme crise
on vient de se fa bouquet à joe rogan
j'ai fait
afoc à chaque fois que tu peux compter
si je veux des bonnes affaires
ces malades se dit juste aller aller
retour elle était juste mais on ya
l'aide des jo pour qu'on fasse une coupe
d'autres pas de casse mais s'était dit
pas de gars ce genre cool à faire mais
qui n'étaient pas des médias majeurs qui
rogen s'est rajouté fait que je serai
vraiment content qu'il a faim qui était
wild ou que j'ai senti qui est un peu
mon l'alpha j'arrive avec un pantalon
spylo et pendant longtemps je fais de
l'humour m'intéresse fait juste une
couple d'années quitte sanglote par un
texte allemand n'a parquet que c'était
tellement fiable lui estime qu'il vaut
faire joe rogan tabarnak un gode park ex
drogué tout le monde tripet on arrive kg
indie ferry mais non merci d'être là il
fait arrête avec ton ami peut rester
dans le green room nous autres on va
aller faire le parc as les cheveux et
hip hop s'embrassant vous nous avez
bouquet les deux non non non non c'est
juste que je suis là on avait déjà
annoncé sur twitter que ça l'aide - qui
lui on avait des clans on est rentrés
date le loft et comme d'hab n'achetez
pas ben pilar jeu savant de commencer
leurs organes fait et je suis vraiment
désolé ptom pauvre elle est désolée du
malentendu c'est juste horrible comme
camargue et ses poches et bauchi l'oeil
et au fait tu veux tu veux tu vraiment
qu'il fasse que j'ai fait ce serait cool
pour vrai la part celui lui vit au-delà
d'un christ commentaires la toute jeune
homme qui va se faire car avec ça hockey
balle 19 aigles est allé le chercher
mais j'y fais tabarnak ça a été un oui
par mouvance avant de rentrer comment
lui c'est qu'il n'ya pas parler tant que
par l'état qui la loterie mais il m'a
dit mais je comprenais rogaine que
google rachète mais lui quand même
d'erreurs qui connaissait assez bien mon
qu il connaissait
c'est bien ma vie mais il connaît cette
focale sur place avec le mtq comme je
suis désolé je le connais pas je les ai
jamais vus c'était un pur fantasme
mais mister soap et alyssa prestige pour
est tué quelqu'un il m'aidera cacher le
cas tu as parlé de la culture mais
complètement son opinion à tous ces
trucs tarit pas ouvrir ma première
entrevue radio quand j'ai sorti mon
album ça j'ai sorti mon album à peu près
en même temps que l'espèce de scandale
que les filles sont moins payés dans le
domaine les filles sont toujours moins
pays ont sans droit mais dans le domaine
de la musique le steak offre le gros
inde le gros stikeman de ce moment le
plus à ma pme comme bonjour non je pense
mon entrevue belle victoire à san bruno
je pense quoi déjà les femmes sont moins
payées la musique je ride est moins vrai
que c'est 4 5 ans mon album et son
maillage je peux vraiment pour semer
tichri vraiment qu'un dead poets pour
atteindre les portes à quoi la sécurité
de même deux places et si jamais ce que
tu vaux d'ici demain ça sera mon chapeau
à n'importe quel site plus avec 10
formés parce que pour vrai la ligue
email
bah oui c est moi je relis des enfants
que j'ai dit c'est trop beau c'est
chinoise nous allons les mêmes même les
règles du journalisme sont floues -les
ces mêmes les règles d'éthique
un journalisme c'est flou maillet monde
mais auteurs préférés qui touche qui est
un journaliste des offres de rigueur ça
existe pour ces gens là non médecins
constatent ils
[Rires]
et voilà ça s'appelle le grammont amis
dans la taca script un mois comme un
personnage de final fantasy
alors c'est moi ou pas de quatre on a
reçu naruto les amis du quartier guillot
un pokémon schéma qui laisse le pokémon
services les les masses le stand hall
d'or
ouais j'avais tellement de cartes même
encore aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est
quand même le plus nommé neveu binya
s'ils écoutent pokémon sérieusement
encore ça ça aux américains des
générations à wil hahn ex aequo les 150
millions 10 ans à 3 km en bourse va pas
durer longtemps
non ça va marcher encore c'est juste que
tu as des amis jouent un énorme boum
mais ça fonctionne et détiennent des
filles qui me diraient acheter avec mon
chum au centre-ville hier encore le jeu
de maillots rentrée les nouvelles
générations
ce n'est pas juste avec les 105 ans je
recommence à jouer là bas ouais parce
que pendant trois semaines les rues
étaient pleines louis park
le grand fossé avec un peu c'est
l'université laval il y avait
c'était justement qui se connectent leur
sel dans l'hommage à terrebonne dans le
temps plus tard fournier des vêtements
des personnes âgées que les enfants tout
mais ça c'est vrai dd gates jack sinon
prendre action leur seule entrée de
gamme mais quel oeil et jeux vidéo
japonais s'est fait faire un vélo le
genre rubis de celle sur son vélo à tous
aux pokémon gold american à un capot
cameron des lycées genre celle ci comme
taillée coûté 8 mai pierre façon c'est
top des pokémon gauche ça résonne dans
ma tête que je vois ce genre de truc qui
pourrait vraiment blanc mais la série
qu'exerce exagérées tout le temps la
beauce et assistance à ses clients nous
amuser les thrips le japon qui genre si
c'est vraiment lui ce qu'ils disent et
si tu peux l'imaginer ça existe à tokyo
capable d'imaginer la patente les ça
existe là bas est seul il vous a fait en
octobre expansion des téléréalités et
télé réalité la beauce et kinshasa ne te
fout des enfants
la dalle et coûtera zéro euro
j ai demandé à david guetta alias au
japon de ramener en taille mais en vrai
c'est fait charlelie la poignée des
pizzas italiennes place puis genre y
avait plusieurs étages puis plus tu
monter d'un étage plus en plus d'être hp
lui dis-je t'arriver je t'arrête et jaro
milieu puis elle avait dit me ramener
c'est quand même encore je mange une
pomme heynckes qui tente accueille des
robots des robots aux poudres beaucoup
de petites filles non mais on a pigé
dans l'histoire loi qui est telle et en
taillant tout d un homme sont ils sont
obligés de faire avec des énormes seins
sinon sinon trop parler des petites
filles
pour ce qui est joli une loi qui fait
que jean fauque les sainsois de tels
grosso a laissé ses pensionnaires manie
la wii
ça serait trompé d eau à mes gars en
tout cas
long silence en lan mais on sentait que
la porno la baule souvent c'est exact
c'est souvent des tipis ca c c'est un
peu passé kiwi d'arghandab une série
d'entrevues avec des pointes store c'est
un gars sur le double c'est belkacem ji
à l'attaqué puis lui fait une série n'a
vu que vous faites après 124 points clés
baptisée mango c'est la passion mais la
sexualité ou jamais pour la revenait non
mais j'ai hâte de videla portage vice là
dessus que la bo
le monde tout le monde et c'est le
bateau recasement le monde fait plus en
couple mon appui d'intérêt a fait en
couple mais il ya des endroits où tu
veux pour te coller gens c'est comme si
ça allait vite grâce comme 3d pro street
fait juste connu pour avoir l'affection
et à flatter ce mot les points sont à la
ils ont sans tain vous irez pacolli je
trouve ça plus normal en guimet pays
brûle advanced c1 personnelle que les
colis
[Musique]
c'est un personnel c'est ça la force la
différence est là parce que ben laden
soit pas de relation d'affection tu
imites le tu vas chercher de l'affection
de sept ans dans une société où si on
dit tout est rendu ultra impersonnel
belle aussi ceux qui l' amant qui lui
manque il une théorie font plus
d'enfants puis les problèmes de la
société ultra vieillissante et camions
la moyenne d'âge je sais pas c'est quoi
mais c'est faux kim byung hun peter paul
jobs vient ce sont les versions a bien
bougé j'ai une femme asiatique et faye
et envoûtant et une batterie ya non mais
t'as la jeune fille car canada gucci
s'est écrié meurtrier
non mais je serais pour réagit gilles
poux le conscientiser chemin
c'est ta blonde qui va jouer dans sa
ronde au hazé m
puis c'est pour les mauvaises raisons je
sais vraiment pas ce que c'est
exactement parce que c'est une figure
littéralement s'est rendu sur le
véganisme tous deux quittent flows
récurrents à cause de l est comme big
anguilles mais je me dis o'keefe a créé
le monde si - jeu m'a bien comment tout
poil ils vont me juger de jugement
s mais peu importe maintenant peu
importe la raison 113 exact on est déçu
mais j'arrête pas de penser à ce qui
m'attend mais à midi c'était vraiment
beau questionne parce que des fois je
parle ils disent que je parle comme si
j'étais un gosse pilotes on est en train
de devenir des super humain n'était
qu'un petit prince du meilleur du groupe
en mer la fille tu fais des humains
c'est très exactement
c'est exactement comme ça mais je
voulais dire michi mais éventuellement
un genre où je sais mais pas
nécessairement c'est juste qu'on veut
donner lesquels tout le moins pas tant
les affaires qui est comme lego font
plus les filles font plus tout ça ça va
se mélanger puis aura plus de ceux qui
ont déjà une fille s'est même agacé de
même ça va j'essaie des êtres humains
puis ça va pas quand même quatre ans
lève tout le les flottes à société
hippique des normes qui décode il reste
pas quelque chose de biologie qui fait
que quand une différence d'un gap inc
je me suis pas assez posé la question a
excellé mais je pense que non
je pense que c'est comme simone de
beauvoir a dit on naît pas femme on le
devient
c'est comme quand tu mets deux enfants 1
2 pen fille à côté le camp son bébé il
ya peu de différence est qu'en même
temps la puberté à puberté c'est ça qui
comme toi tu être plus de poils en face
ça n'est pas l'écrit encore une fois
mais je ne sais pas je pense qu'il est
facile et des normes la cct encore une
fois le facteur cepl tant que ça les
stresse on enlève tout seul ne savons
pas ce que tu com qu'est-ce qui te dis
pas que si il ya 400 ans
il ya mille ans les femmes ont commencé
à ses plis c'est peut-être la raison
pourquoi on a moins de vols que vous
l'on sait pas s'il elle est à erie de
l'évolution peut-être certaines
personnes ne seraient pas nous le même
temps quelqu'un biologistes des parts de
quelque chose que j'avais la javel à la
diction ce qui ma blonde ask question
beaucoup par rapport à vos lettres qui
ont souvent après avoir vu son numéro
avec martin matte
sur le gala de l'école de saint quentin
et congo les 30 au lit 30 à très fort
chez louise parce qu'ils viennent
aujourd'hui qui est presque là c'était
le c'était la parité pour avoir numérisé
c'était comme une façon vous le faisiez
comme si c'était toi qu'avec son texte à
lui qui disait que ça devrait elle
apparaît tpiy lui m'a vexé parce qu'on
n'était pas d'accord qu'on attend on
était vraiment un conte closely ils
disaient qu'ils y croyaient pas seul à
pas et hyper rapide moi je dis que je
croyais à ses côtés comme le fruit crâne
mais où est-ce qu'on est d'accord toutes
les deux de dire ce qu'on va dire
puis on a réussi à se mettre d'accord
tient un homme genre de foi comme seul
homme blanc de 50 ans qui est un peu
plus de droite puis une fille hyper de
gauche de 25 ans on a un sens mais
quelque chose ensemble
saks et ça m'a été c'est la plus grande
fierté c'est bon tu sais ça ça veut dire
qu'on est capable dans cct de s'entendre
si la fin ouais c'est ça moi j'avais
justement le j'avais la discussion avec
ma blonde parce que je me disais c'est
moi il y avait là fardeloup j'ai encore
bien aussi au festival d'été puis il
s'en est mordu les doigts si c'est comme
s'il n'y avait pas assez réfléchi à la
question avant pis moi tu vois je reste
je mettais pas posé la question plus
large d'un système mal en pis
sont ce que elle maudit kiev qui m'a
fait réaliser que mon opinion tête guézy
n'était pas biaisé mettait pas abouti
c'est qu'à mots dits oui effectivement
c'est en même temps la parité t'empêche
des belges en mettant des gars plus
talentueux ou ou meilleure que des
feuilles de prendre cette place là sauf
que le point que la nappe ensuite ses
droits mais sitôt la parité il voit plus
de filles qui vont dire moi c'est ça je
veux faire parce que plus de faits qu'il
faut si c'est ça c'est comme ça il faut
que je refasse un plan de 120 ans ouais
c'est sûr si c'est comme l'apa et en ce
moment ça va être chiant pour me temps
ils voient déjà 5 6 ans mais après ça il
ya des filles dans cinq six ans ils vont
avoir plus puisqu'il n'a plus que le
talent et se développe tout sur moi je
n'avais pas mais c'est historiquement
hystériquement cessé de même aussi
rejeté les droits de vote au début les
familles à l'épaule il ya les potes en
voter c'est après cela que j'en sais
maintenant c'est normal pour nous c'est
simplement que les femmes votent autant
que les amis ce que c'est intéressant de
se positionner sur le puits par rapport
à ensuite à la question de dire est ce
qu'il ya des différences fondamentales
physique clairement y est physique qui
en amante allemand je sais pas je suis
dit je sais pas si vite les hommes et ça
c'est vraiment la question est
intéressante et comme souvent qui sont
utilisées par des hommes pour dire aux
mêlées pour diminuer la femme c'est pour
dire à la fin peut pas être si peut pas
être ce pas ce qui est biologiquement
sont pas capables cpie le en fait
maintenant ses cliques et fait ses
recherches le cd 51 californie se
souvient s'est basé sur pas grand chose
c'est juste un argument pour dire pour
discréditer mais tu es
tennisman les animaux comme d'autres lui
demander quel animal sur marc des
différences de comportement entre les
morts dans la famille le tea party c'est
pas fou de penser que peut-être
quelqu'un qui en a qui est en maternelle
les recherches dit c'est pas
nécessairement des affaires c'est mou je
vois pas ce genre d'exemple sont
meilleurs ou positivement at-il
toutefois que les hommes c'est on est
plus impulsif cela la science le dit il
des traits comme ceux il ya bien plus
d'hommes en syrie via leur société
tomassi mangeant des mac en trop lente
ou qui ont eu des problèmes j'aurais des
viols camp était bébé tu commences
épaules été violée en même temps si on
n'y a pas dit si on y avait du bon c'est
pas grave ils suivent en psychologie
après l'essai jusqu'à un petit goût viol
y passera pas la même chose qui se fait
via les mêmes genre d'accompagnement je
pense c'est moche pour ça que la
question est plus va plus loin que ça
parce qu il
l' influence de la société et partout
dans les années partout dans tout ce
qu'on vous convient il était difficile
de réduire ce sais que c'est impossible
en fait de réduire sera simplement la
base deux essais ça commence comme on
dit on n'est pas scientifique fait qu'on
pose plusieurs questions mais c'est que
le sénat par les partis qui peut donner
des pistes c'est de tchéquie à travers
les époques et travers les sociétés
suspects ne s'étaient pas par aigle un
str marre d'être et qu'ils sont
constat encore une fois tu essaies ce
souci-là était du patriarcat si c'était
les activités comme les savons et est
moins développé aussi les gens là c'est
clair on en parle c'est le rapport ok
les gars sont vance à la discussion
texan un petit veulent comprendre le ccc
genre il ya des fois élégante et sur
internet qui disent des choses vraiment
et que tu vois qui ayant peur réfléchi
mais qui travaillent qui sont avec eux
puis il comprendra un peu plus
moi je dis aux filles à fond chez vous
peut tout y est déjà je comprends que
c'est fort champ m'attendais à ce que ça
marche des fois de recevoir jean trois
fois par jour un thé bonne pour une
fille je n'aime pas les films les
habitudes tu sais mes collègues c'est
mes amis on sait du moins possible pas
quelque chose de positif pour moi qui ai
tempo les filles d'habitude sont pas de
rôle regardons pas actif à chapais de
sept pieds déjà essaie d'expliquer ou
genre capitole un message qui était fait
pipi colonnes ces cas mais c'est du
célèbre des fois les com de postes fâché
je comprends mais oui je sais ça fait
qu'ils aient apprécié 1 2 qui plein de
bon boulot en piqué jean type qui veut
juste comprendre mais tu vois tout de
suite face ouellette a pas des gens qui
va l'aider
je ne dirais pas plus fort mais quand
même
la magie c'est fait
c'est une excellente question qu'est-ce
qui est ce qui est ce que tu as une
piste de réponse de caisse qui qu'est ce
qui fait qu'un on aime voir ce qu'est ce
qui fait que les films d'horreur les
livres d'horreur les livres de genre en
fait moi ce sont quelque chose qu'on
recherche activement même si c'est moi
mais admettons je regarde un film
d'horreur ça me fait pas me sentir bien
il ya une espèce de quelque chose qu'on
recherche lanceur pourrait belge pas si
j'en cherche pas toutes la même faille à
des gens qui cherchent uniquement le
gore qui cherchent une énième voit des
signes très très très sanglantes je
pensais le côté puis pour ceux sans
aucun jugement de valeur mais le côté
qui de le côté enfant du spectateur qui
tout énervé de voir 5 hir voile les
effets spéciaux ayant un gros plat d'un
oeil crevé une cervelle qu'on n'ouvre
pire nous pensons très intéressant
personnellement mais quand je te quitte
jamais seul donc si le côté immature de
l'horreur qu'on va chercher le cerveau
reptilien le clip de voir ça mais qui
implique aucune émotion parce que que tu
devrais voir quand tu vois quelqu'un
faire ouvrir la page ouvrir le ventre en
gros plan ça devrait éclairer en suivant
les gens qui aiment ces films là ce que
ça fait c'est qu'ils trouvent ça cool
les bras alors on voit que cela on est
tous premier degré de voir le plus de sa
possible c'est pas trés émotivement
implique un mois ce que j'aime le mieux
dans des halos roda et scully que
certaines personnes aiment aussi cesser
le côté explorer son côté sombre en fait
explorer le côté sombre de l'être humain
pas les voir et pourquoi on un sort bine
c'est parce que et on sait que ça existe
on veut approcher sama prochain dans la
vraie vie c'est dangereux long le fait
de manière sécuritaire et comme la
montagne russe un taux de montagnes
russes
tapas match ict arrivera rien tu sais
que normalement elle à la traque à
rousseau pop que normalement il devrait
pas continuer tout droit a dit m
alors lire lire un livre à sensation
faut stopper ça c'est que 8,8 des
émotions fortes vis des émotions que
d'un côté et tu vis pas normalement
il est suivi par procuration travers un
livre et ça s'appelle j'ai ce côté
ludique de côté thrill c'est ouf
il m'est rien arrivé heureusement ce
s'écouter montagnes russes mais si j'ai
certaines me roma qu'ils ne sont que sow
c'est juste une bonne rails de montagnes
russes mais un ado qui aussi en même
temps qu'une raid on essaie de les
explorer des choses un peu plus enfouies
au fond de nous un peu plus notre
inconscient à notre côté sombre la bête
en nous qui sommeille pire je pense
qu'on a toutes une bête qui sommeille
n'a pas d'école surgir jamais pu tant
mieux mais je pense qu'on peut lille
explorée par procuration et ça donne
et ça c'est démontrer c'est en effet de
catharsis la catharsis de vie des
émotions fortes par procuration nourrir
le méchant dans nous et ce à deux c'est
comme ça depuis que le monde est monde
je dire l'été on y servait à seul le
ternir et dans l'antiquité ça racontait
des histoires de ma part c'était moins
gras fait qu'yves demain mais pour
raconter des histoires de moeurs
d'inceste et ray pour sortir notre
catharsis on allait voir dira d'aider
des gens fait manger au cirque de rome
la villa des gladiateurs qui se situait
tout ça on eu des exécutions publiques
jusqu'au début du 20e siècle où il
fallait voir et des pendaisons cela
place publique ou de la guillotine tous
orne et sortir un tout ton méchanceté
commence comme un vidange d'huile
pendant la vieille huile que projette
sur quelqu'un d'autre
et comme maintenant dans la vraie vie on
efface de plus en plus les traces de
violence de vraies violences et
écoeurait coup ci mais notre besoin
catharsis est encore là car main mais
c'est la fiction qui prend le relais et
pour ça que la fiction est devenue si
violente parce que aux faucons livre qu
est passé de violence l'appui la fiction
c'est grâce à moi personnellement si
monfils a à choisir entre un autre garde
un film d'art à bangor ou de les voir
des gens s'entretuent dans un arène ben
oui j'aime quand même mieux que
j'aimerais mieux qu'ils regardent un
film
je m'arrête plus sceptiques en compte
c'est sûr que le premier travail que tu
as fort et surtout perdre cette relation
si tes relations se répare pas par le
travail que tu fais sur toi là tu peux
travailler sur la relation mais premier
travail se fait surtout les officiels
c'est clair c'est que l'europe sait que
ce soit dans ses amitiés là ton couple
ou si un problème
première chose à l'examen deux c6 toi
moi même je pense le sait puis après
c'est comme tu dit si tu verras si
amanissi sitôt partenaires a vraiment
des problèmes il me ferait du bon père
répétition et c'est sûrement moins de
problèmes ouais non c'est sûr métiers
cam et on met ça peut partir de toits de
ces éventuels man s'appelle dans
n'importe quelle situation
ça peut vraiment répit puis des fois
juste de changer une petite affaire de
chez soi ça peut ça peut crissement
genre réparer des relations ou améliorer
vraiment des trucs tu sais pas et le spi
rade par la presse yves la négative qui
mollit jacques qui sont autour de moi
que j'aime beaucoup pis que je pense que
ici même je vois je leur demande déjà
dotés chacun dé foi ddt tête peu fermé
où chaque est quelque chose de juste à y
penser que je ressens sud si la personne
est la mal à l'aise par un événement du
passé ou propres tu as the et est ravie
qu'on a parlé tout pile et ben oui à qui
je trouve que des fois quand il fait tel
truc j'ai moins c'est toi qui jeudi a
mené la partie à cette personne là parce
que justement déclenchée par quelque
chose que tu fais peut-être fait que tu
viens d'en parler c'est un super temps
par l'attitude sans jugement pee wee
puis ce qui est bon aussi de souligner
l'intention avant tout mon intention
c'est d'être comme support à l'aise avec
tout ce qu'on a une bonne hamiti ford
est construit c'est ça mon intention
était de 50 euros une façon pour que ça
marche
2 puis console en synergie de simon
intentions si de grands dîners à thème
etc tout parce que j'aime quand on donne
10 livres pour la liqueur et 26 et
différenciante aventure avec tout parce
que j'aime ce que tu fais pipi je
t'apprécie hantise un bel team dit que
c'est par exemple de la difficulté avec
moi travaillons mais pour qu'on puisse
être capable d'être dans cette invention
ça ça fait partie de la communication la
communication c'est tellement essentiel
a tout pigé vraiment l'impression que
que c'est c'est souvent sous-évalués jeu
dans les interactions humaines qu'en ce
moment et des gens aussi qui je pense
ont honte est blessé par des trucs du
passé ou des trucs sont à jouer qui ont
jamais pris le temps de soigner puisque
ça va ça va les suivre toute leur vie je
pense en syrie
je me suis pas parano je n'ai pas parlé
de 65 pts qui manquait peut-être pas
avec moi petit paul lemay moi je pense
que c'est il faut c'est inévitable de
penser par ce processus le si justement
tu veux être dans quelque chose de plus
harmonieux de sa pré remplie tu peux ne
pas vouloir subir est sur la table c'est
un chipset a participé nécessairement
mal mais moi je pense que oui quand ni
quand même donc une relation avec ta
blonde sommes des amis peu importe la
famille ça va mal put envie que ça aille
mieux bien saviez moi je pense de
blessures du passé qu'il faut que je
travaille et [ __ ] mettre le doigt
dessus puis exact le déni c'est une
méthode facile qui est commune de
dilbeek sur pied collègues puisqu'elle
s'est souvent j'imagine que pas mal à un
but ça peut être la seule option passé
parce que c'est trop dur hausse aussi
impossible pour l'instant mais justement
dans le long terme si tu viens jamais
régaté c'est beau boulot pour lille et
paris
ces crédits même même physiquement là ça
peut venir
moi j'ai l'impression de ma vie d'avoir
vécu des événements particuliers qui
m'ont affecté le dos par exemple
vraiment la tête pas dans l'eau ou aux
ventes tout simplement ou autre et ce
qui se passe est manquée une connexion
entre toutes les émotions qu'on vit avec
notre corps physique intéressant puis
définitivement le stress un lien c'est
sur ce qu'est le stress peut venir
me suis plusieurs formes voûtée en
stress émotionnel ça reste un stress là
c'est un stress des relations de
tristesse de quelque chose qui pesait
sur toi ça peut être un événement
traumatique ça tristan longtemps exact
je suis d'accord ça peut sûrement
barnier avait trop physique un certain
moment il ya eu un grain de bayeux
encore un trend qui dit tu es tout ce
qui est toxique dans ta vie élimine le
pit tout ce qui est négatif dans ta vie
shoot le dôme puis il malgré tout je
trouve une sanction en ce qui est
toxique puisqu'il négatif ou
problématiques une fille si les gens
prennent le réflexe de justes tout
bloquer les émotions négatives
les personnes qui croient être toxique
de leur entourage censier de comprendre
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que c'est
toxique pourquoi est-ce que c'est nocif
du tram ans tu vieillis plus tu
commences à jamais avoir confronté
quelque chose de négatif jamais avoir
essayé de solutionner quelque chose de
négatif que je prendrai le dire il ya
des relations clairement toxiques
oui mais si tu n'arrives pas à voir
pourquoi exact parce que non seulement à
qui tu leur as pu mettre sera pas
capable de repérer un autre genre de
relation toxique comme ceux qui veulent
parce que c'est ce à quoi du service -
faîtière déjà toxiques y en a partout
dans le monde
puis en douce à montréal autour de toi
dans ton entourage peu importe il y en a
je pense que s'il se débarrasse de lui
aurait très bien joué tant mieux si
cette taxe est pour toi puis ce furent
là dedans parfait mais ce truc pourquoi
parce que le il y en a d'autres qui vont
réapparaître à manille pitt sera pas
pourquoi a t'il de la source
ma belle-mère à percer les antennes de
boule de neige les antennes de boules de
neige
si ma tante et l'effet boule de neige
c'est quand tu descends cours de
tournage a grossi par amener à devenir
inarrêtable depuis les antennes de
boules à neige c'est ce qui te permet de
voir quelque chose qui vote qui pourrait
avoir l'effet d'une boule de neige puis
de juste le quitter avant voir des
signes avant coureurs d'une relation
toxique mettons le j'ai déjà vécu ça par
le passé j'ai réalisé qu est ce qui me
plaisait pas dans ce une fois que
c'était fermé
tu as quand même temps que tu tues une
relation amoureuse qui finit plus de se
rencontrer qu'en plus cette personne a
fait quelque chose qui qui te rappelle
quelque chose que tu sais que toi tu
serais pas capable de vivre avec a même
pensé ça parce que sinon au synode en
boule de neige ccct les règles des
règles écrites d'une relation s'écrit
vraiment au début j'ai dit à l'afp il a
fait une phase qui est pas le premier
ça fait six mois je l'aï dit on m'a rien
dit après six mois je vais plus loin ça
aussi mais juste il espèce de rencontre
quelqu'un pileux il est comme la période
de limites sont ou étaient ce qu'était
leur dire que t'as pas le droit de dire
puis le à m'amener la dynamique
s'installe puis ça reste seul défaut sur
sa bonne pas descendante et des gens qui
ont des comportements anti émeute ont
aidé à 12h ou des batteurs de femmes
ces premières journées s'installe
tranquillement track and trace
tranquillement au début ce n'est pas
ultra attentif ou si c'est pour
connaître ses singles eu des petites
actions qui fait que tu en vois dans
cette d'assaut dans ce chemin et le bain
à prendre c'est sûr que si tu es déjà vu
ou déconnecté reconnaît rapidement sur
ce comportement là c'est celle que oui
cela oblige ça fonctionnera pas avec moi
exact c'est avoir la force de dire si
c'est ça demande beaucoup de force
reconnaître ce que tu veux puisque tu
veux pop il n'y a pas de dire
cette relation là où cette personne le
m'apporte potes parce que je dans la vie
c'est pour moi c'est parce que si ce
texte a raconté une nouvelle personne
cet expert anti et les débuts de
relations pis la personne peut la
trouver babelway mais d'être capable de
dire non qui est moi ce que je veux la
vie c'est pas ce n'est pas facile c'est
pas facile les jeunes latendresse mois
puis dirais c'est bien cool que vous
dites quelle forme allait tous les
secteurs puis ils ont raison 9 puis
c'est zéro facile puis mais je pense
c'est ici de dire ce que tu as envie que
ça change que pour toi bleus pour toi le
site était plus heureux là dans le lac
je dirais que pour toi sinon je voudrais
tu as toi c'est ta responsabilité moi je
pense que tout le monde mais ça c'est la
responsabilité de de kiev avec qui se
tiennent de où ils sortent le soir ce
chercheur à telle place et que ces
personnes on est tout le temps mardi
moi je t'ai qui régissent ce qui me suit
et mennecy platner de sortir avec les
autres ayant la meilleure personne avec
qui tu sois mais tu entendes puis c'est
d'avoir le courage d'en parler aussi jeu
savant petit à petit avec ces personnes
là pour te l'exemple de concert à tel
endroit ou fait tout le temps seul moyen
pour se jetant de continuation avec vous
mais si vous continuez à faire c'est ben
je viendrai pour la prochaine fois tout
simplement tu pars rapporte que tu dois
parler calmement puis pas dans le
jugement puis sa part des reproches non
plus juste à côté sur comme à droite
sans vraiment la clé de d'abord dé tous
les tous les conflits ou les problèmes
pote pas et en disant ce que toi tu fais
toi moi je dois fait ça mais quand toi
tu fais ça moi ça me fait me sentir
comme si la partie de la décision tu
reviens tu veux continuer à agir de
cette façon là en sachant en
connaissance de cause
je ressens comme ça ben c'est à fait sûr
puis moi ça me rend pas puis mettez côté
de la médaille
non mais des fois tu l'as dit que
c'était moi pour mon intention peut-être
mais tenter de décoder certaines choses
que j'ai pas dit que ce qu'il montre
trop souvent il sera tranché c'est par
exemple je veux dire que quand c'était
le truc
ben j'aime parce que je me sens
intimidée par tous à moto ou à la vue
c'est un triste soir à intriquer fait
que c'est une émotion que ça doit partir
de c'est comme si je te laisse
l'opportunité de me demander ce qu'il
faut tu sais c'est pas ça rend dans une
caté grimaud qui est intrigué puis puis
c'est important de dissocier ces deux
choses la communication c'est pas
important je pense que justement camatte
ont toutes eu d'issue bientôt si tu
décides que satisfaite fait sentir comme
ça une chose disons que ça tu appartiens
ucits et c'est toi qui décide d'être là
dedans mais de pointer la personne du
doigt c'est toi qui me fait ressentir
ces émotions là c'est moi qui choisis me
sentir comme ceux d abord mais comment
on peut trouver une façon pour justement
éviter ce simplement de s'engager pour
des cessions de terrains vraiment bon
mais c'est ce qui est important séparait
les deux puis pied déjà que cet accord
meilleur effet mais c'est ce genre de
conversation le sait le genre de
conversation j'aurais vraiment aimé
écouter plutôt dans ma vie ouais entendu
c'est quoi je pense que cela devrait
être quelque chose qui est tout
simplement appris dans les écoles qui
documentent nicollin commencé vers l'âge
réel débat beta je pense c'est quelque
chose qui serait ce pas important de
mairie de caen ttc plus jeunes de
comprendre qu est-ce qui t'appartient
puis qu'est-ce qui appartient aux autres
c'est si lui décident de forcer comme
chemin les stops affecté par ce décès
heureusement mais crise en grèce qui
n'arrête pas de dire 70
ok mais c'est toi qui décide d'être
gracié par ce travail sur toi ma main je
pense qu'il y moi je pense qu'il devrait
faire des crocs comme ceux déjà de cours
de psycho communication mais travail
existe une formule vestimentaire mais
s'appelle communication consciente et ou
communication non violente qui appelle
des lieux qu'on sort parce que non
violente rixe apporte soudain
d'antécédents même une amie qui m'a va
faire une formation en communication
consciente
puis une formation initiatique d'une fin
de semaine si leur père que j'ai pris me
mets à base naissance de ce type il
avance hier la théorie puis ça monsieur
aujourd'hui tout le temps à me ranger à
mennecy la foule commence à mazamet gb -
de près de proue sur les épaules parce
que je prends plus l'épreuve des autres
dans le sens que je vois plus maintenant
je veux comprendre que sur ce que lui
fait qui me fait sentir demain que moi
je vitales telles émotions 20 c à partir
puis le choc à main qui sur mon bureau
le zouk besoin d'occuper qui aimeraient
communication non-violente communication
consciente c'est un homme qui s'appelle
famille rosenberg qui occupent artiste
est un jeu théorisé ce point exact qui
je ne connais pas beaucoup pression sur
lui mais bref
iliad il ya des séances de sa de
communication non-violente cunca sont
conscientes qu'il ya un groupe qui
s'appelle être consciente a qui font des
conférences à montréal qu'à québec
puis c'est incroyable c'est jean le deal
c'est fou le puy - justement du ma force
et mon ami antoine desrochers qui va
faire c'est mon anniversaire c'est
peut-être trois ans une clinique mené
tout le talent l'énergie dans quinze
parties ont jusqu'à puisque c'est ce
qu'à moi je commence à ressentir quelque
chose la boule qui tu parlais tantôt
banque indienne trop grosse je vais pas
parler de switcher comme d'abord être du
temps du menu du marché de paris que tu
l'espace pour victor sur loire qui
parfait on s'assoira parle fini
qu'est ce que ça fait ce tu dis que des
changements dans ta tête
c'est là tu te rends compte cesser ce
que tu veux vraiment qu'est ce que ça
fait
concrètement comme changement
c'est vraiment un changement tire et tue
quelque chose que tu peux dire que qui
est le seuil est vraiment eu un
changement précis à ce niveau là puisque
logiquement ben je te dirai
psychologiquement willis la réparation
mais je te dirai vraiment dans
l'attitude enlève vision pour la vie
j'ai jamais une vision des plessis que
la vie jamais jamais jamais mais je
voyais vraiment les choses d'un meilleur
angle l'amour d'une autre façon je
voyais mon corps d'une autre façon
puisque le cas changer aussi facture
void avec des changements physiquement
psychologique si ça change c'est que je
te dirais que c'était surtout la vision
la vision de ma vie je me sentais que je
devais le bon patin que je me rendais ou
ce que je voulais me rendre
c'est vraiment nombreux thérapie dans le
fond le sac coupe la testostérone
s'adonne restera c'est ça qui fait que
c'est sûr mais il faut penser que dit
clairement penser qu'il y ait des
changements physiques mais même de ta
manière de réfléchir cinquième
changement le cerveau mais c'est parce
que les hormones sont tellement
importantes en termes d'attentes on vous
aussi ça c'est vraiment tout un
changement chimique le quinqua chimiques
hormonal préoccupe à viola petit piper
mot plein plein de choses qui sont
réduits avec les romains puis j'ai
vraiment je les ai vraiment vu le
changement du côté amos sexuelle
c'est vraiment différent ma vision de
tout ça le change et c'est un feeling
différent une femme souvent c'est un
feeling sexuel différent c'est là une
façon d'aimer différemment peut-être pas
pour tout le monde mais comme
généralement par n'allait pas que ça
vient vraiment même changé sur qui s'est
un peu entité ministre est en train de
dire dans un sens tic ayant un cerveau
deux hommes qui eux savent autre femme
si différents des leurs
je trouve ça intéressant car si fort
c'est exactement parce qu'on peut on
peut avoir des discussions mettant
toutes les discussions qui ont peu à
voir avec un homme pour une femme qui
parle ensemble de comment il voit la
sexualité comme un voile amour tu peux
pas vraiment comprendre ce que l'autre
te dis parce que tu ce futur pas vécu
mais mais toi tu as vu les deux croûte
et oui mais ça c'est fou parce que tu
peux réaliser à quel point bas à quel
point c'est différent vraiment je trouve
ça vraiment même intéressant pour ses
pas pu voir la différence des deux
oreilles
justement une personne spéciale mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe non mais en tout
cas mais moi ça me fascine
pauvre et ça je trouve ça extrêmement
intéressant d'un point de vue
psychologique de savoir que
que une réaction chimique peut changer
il peut changer quelque chose dans une
personne ouais
dernièrement qu'une m je parlais de mes
amis qui travaillent le verset megal qui
fait le lien entre les les athlètes et
les universités dans le fonds pour les
athlètes universitaires enquête puis ils
viennent de passer une règle pour les
athlètes 30 mai parce que ça c'est quand
même taux de ch et c'est maintenant un
homme qui devient une femme ou un homme
qui est une femme qui est ce qui tombe
et yonne avec les femmes où est-ce
qu'ils convainquent les hommes parce que
tu es tout dépendant de de ton niveau
changement si c'est exactement le
pendant ton niveau de changement
hormonal tic
mettons que tu peux être une femme mais
avec un taux de testostérone beaucoup
plus haut qui va faire que tu veux qu'on
retient contre les femmes beach veut
juste être dans le fond un homme qui
confessions avec des femmes outil un
corps d'homme condition des femmes
mais finalement la règle qui ont pas
cessé tu dois avoir le taux d'hormones
qui est selon je pense le gouvernement
du canada qui classe dans un des deux
genres des fois il ya des femmes qui
peuvent avoir un taux ramené beaucoup
plus haut que ça existait une sortie aux
olympiques goni de médaille d'or
olympique au 100 m monsieur besson n'ont
malheureusement ce n'est celle africaine
sont africaines puis elle s'est alors
vraiment une chef d' homme une voix
d'homme pythie le naturellement nouveau
testostérone ultra élevée écrit quand
même fallu carte sd phase de tests de
féminité pour pour compétitionner qu'on
voulait que la classe vraiment dans
officiellement avec les femmes parce que
je pense que même qu'il fallait qu'elle
trouve des moyens de réduire son niveau
testostérone pour être éligible à ces
deux or c'est bizarre c'est que vous
trouvez thiès qui titre ce bizarre et
moi je trouve ça moi je trouve ça
parlait jesse ma blonde ats salle
intéresse beaucoup le thé la communauté
lgbt qc ca participe personnellement
puis on en avait parlé de ce sujet
l'autre c'est justement mon amie de
lynette pied
en principe comme toi aussi à cerner
comment comment approcher cette question
là dessus parce que personne qui
voudrait que les femmes les hommes
compétition ensemble jusqu'à ce serait
juste une faible c'est plate de le dire
mais c'est au niveau sportif au niveau
biologique ses pilotes je remettais à ça
remet pas du tout en doute le droit de
se définir soi même puis de choisir qui
convient au nom exact c'est sa femme
selon passé ce qui se dit ce n'est pas
non plus demander à sigean le de pas
faire de sport a nancy l'annoncé de sa
liberté personnelle tiff qu'est ce qu'on
faisait avec les gens qui rentrent pas
dans les codes binaires trop difficile
pis c'est super sensible comme je suis
jamais tant lequel est la femme
alain tourné ce sera trop haut sur le
côté des garçons ouais c'est ce qui est
c'est ce qu'ils disent est bien avec
bien comme les statistiques assez clair
c'est un niveau un talk show peut pas
dire de taux de change même pas comme
c'est quoi le vocabulaire mais pis puis
les ans alors dérange l'époque sans
savoir que sa méthode qui voyait
l'équipe avec une femme et si je sais
mais comment ça vient c'est quoi la
définition de la femme puis de l'homme
d'enfants pour tous en même temps parce
que l'étudient clar maillot si la femme
a tout de la lada d'un homme a le chef
d'un homme à la voix d'un homme le tout
d'un homme mais mettons à 9 h 26 oui
comme une femme
mais ces femmes qui ont des grosses voix
mais
mais sa star comme une femme si je dit
pas c est tranchant puis est un
cheminement pour devenir un homme moi je
la mettrais du quotidien
oui parce que personnellement
s'identifie comme un homme au bon prix
alors écoute je suis complètement
d'accord sur moi j'avais pas et je
n'avais pas de bonnes j'avais juste pas
de réponse parce que je me disais 6 et 6
je me disais rien alpha est un autre
exemple dans le monde du mmo une autre
athlète que je m'estime son nom mais
c'est une femme trans qui quittent
arrivée dans le land du combo quant aux
lions et mixtes art martial en ayant
déjà fait sa transition qui
accomplissent tenu compte des femmes qui
sait à
les démolisse et elle étudiera tabac
c'est parce qu'elle avait une force
d'hommes le tiki on parle même plus de
sport tlc la sécurité des personnes qui
sont une femme et avec la thérapie ça
change la muscu et je pense que c'est
dans la règle qui tu sais que tu peux
c'était un site une énorme et est une
femme puis que tu fais de transition tu
peut compétitionner contre les femmes
si justement avec la thérapie tutut à
travers de l'autre côté de ça les clubs
d'être à 100 ok c'est ce qu'ils
faisaient là je me dis côté technique
c'est un milieu qui empêche pas d'avoir
d'objectivité que ailleurs il ya un
homme paumé au moyen de pape sy mais
correct c'est un peu ça le débat aussi
des fois c'est biologie versus ce qui
construit par la société le titre peu
peut-être être biologiquement n'est un
homme est identifié au construit social
qui la femme plus où je sais ce 2 2
de refuser d'être ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle représente jusqu'à temps que
transilien le plein le demande dans
sociétés qui veulent juste je chante la
société sylis où les genres je pense que
tu peux décider de ne pas ce que tu veux
dans la vie vous et moi j'ai aucun
problème avec cela mais je vous dis donc
on prend même le temps que les gens
soient heureux avec leur choix puis que
les gens soient bien c'est ce qu'il est
il important
j'ai l'impression que yeux du monde qui
justement pour reprendre l'exemple de
légende qui je trouve qu'il s'est
construit une espèce de de following
ultra intéressés par ld je pense que
prendre vraiment de ce qui montre sur
ces réseaux sociaux vraiment de quoi
être positif pour pour pour les
personnes qui la suivent
j'ai l'impression que ça le je réfléchis
à avoir et je pense encore au quotidien
mais j'ai l'impression que ça l'est un
rôle positif dans la société qui a des
gens qui soient qui a et ce rôle j'ai
l'impression que c'est encore nouveau
encore quelque chose qu'on ignore qu on
connaît très mal mais j'ai l'impression
que sur le long terme
certaines personnes peuvent pas en train
de dire les gens qui font juste vendre
des trucs comme des panneaux
publicitaires mais j'ai l'impression que
certaines personnes ont un rôle à jouer
dans l'éducation de la société parce que
les réseaux sociaux sont là qu'on le
veuille ou non
maintenant comment qu'on s'assure que
les gens je te demande les enfants qui
ont un salaire dans leurs mains à 10 ans
sont capables d'avoir des exemples
positifs mais si ça sauf que après
qu'est-ce qui est un exemple pour ce qui
est un peu juste lysandre l'aimé on
parle de plein d'affaires de pleinement
de ce que maintenant tout le monde on
s'active une somme qui si souvent on dit
c'est ouais c'est un exemple au style un
exemple aussi mais c'est quoi un exemple
dans ce sens qu'ils aient un exemple
possible de dans son opinion
sauf que mettons ça dépeint après c'est
que y'a personne qui a la science infuse
le
oui moi je t'avais bon exemple la marque
de thé dansant non mais c'est vrai je
dis pas que des fois je trouve que la
ligne est mince entre est ce que c'est
un bon exemple où ça qu'est-ce que ça
démontre quelqu'un qui vit devant son
téléphone qui qui donne son opinion sur
têt certains sujets comme piqué les
jeunes surtout mettant de 14 à 18
boivent leur parole comme de l'eau qui
lâche l'école puis qu'ils disent ben moi
c'est ce que je vais faire je vois
parler au monde dans madame ans nous
allons est en effet moi je pense qu'il
ya plein plein plein de bonnes choses
qui vont sortir d'internet le thé en
général et c'est jusqu'à 10 fois je
trouve que ces evs et le thé comme bien
d affaire justement le lait quand on
parle de chirurgie quand on parle de
sexe quand on parle de thé de sujets que
quant à 14 15 16 7 imputé cet te forger
une opinion plus une personnalité puis
que on passe tellement de temps sur
notre téléphone puis les jeunes aussi le
sait pas différent et moi je me rappelle
je finissais l'école j'allais sur msn
le média changé mais les habitudes
pauvres qui je me dis moi mettons à 14
ans avoir eu ces gens là comme exemple
ces gens là mais je dire je m'inclus là
dedans aussi où a germé et il ya quelque
chose qui est un peu cheap à la réalité
puisque même si oui des fois mettons je
regarde gloria belt qui quitteraient
lgbt qi pita blanc et c'est super ça
c'est génial qu'on puisse parler de ces
sujets là puis qu'on puisse avoir
mais c'est juste qu'il faut je pense
prendre tout un petit peu plus à la
légère
on sait ce que je trouve ces quelques 6
comme devenu super sérieux
pis là on peut opter mettons en jeu si
le gym mon personnage d'influenceurs je
me faire avancer le genre c'est de
l'intimidation puisse comme elle sait on
au rire un peu le aussi de tout seul
point parce que je fais aussi on peut
plus enrayer puissions pas dire bon mois
ce ces capsules par exemple de telle
influence heures je trouve ça aberrant
et un peu comme si comme ce qui est
arrivé avec pays où il ya plein de gens
qui en fait tu payes voyant dans son
pote mon sens mais on n'a pas besoin
d'en faire de même sur internet c'est
juste que l'on dirait que ça fait du
bien à tout le monde de bâches et
collectivement un élu l'ambition mais
une personne c'est alors que y'en a
plein d vidéo horrible puis un peu
gênant pitié avec des opinions qui ont
pas de maudit bon sens pis folk avant de
répondre à ce sens que ça soit ps comme
l'intimidation mais que cette cession
est une kia une discussion mais j'ai
l'impression que beaucoup d'influenceurs
qui n'ont pas le goût de la voir cette
chienlit psicom qui garde moi je fais ce
que je veux le képi tom j'enfile mon
opinion fait que george est vraiment en
droit puis comme will fall
sauf que moi j'ai droite et dire que
j'aime pas ça puis quels sont tes rires
ou que tous ceux superficielle par me
manque mais toi tu as le droit de dire
aussi que mon métier c'est là dans la
boue et je m'en fous nous 6 heures je
sais que je pense qu'ils manquent de
funcom perdre une fan d'internet
ouais c'est vrai je comprends
c'est vraiment d'aider des réflexions
vraiment dans l'air du temps
pepy ces secteurs de mettre le doigt sur
quelque chose que moi aussi je pense
souvent je suis obsédé avec sofa ou
est-ce que ça s'en va c'est quoi lasser
koala est ce que on est juste dans une
transition vers quelque chose d'autre
est ce que c est ce qu on va pas si ble
ment atteindre un moment où est ce qui
va ou plus de règles plus de pissos en
même temps ça enlèverait un petit peu la
patente sans les vrais de l'intérêt du
truc mais c'est complet que je crois qu
une des raisons pourquoi c'est devenu
plus sérieux c'est que c'est devenu une
job c'est une job littéralement ou est
ce que par exemple quelqu'un qui vend un
produit je vais me prendre moi comme
exemple parce que je les fais souvent
des bains je ne peux pour nous balader
sur les deux courses qui pillent
pour que je me mette en scène pour faire
passer un certain message
même si c'est pas une extension très
différente de moi pour me mettre
ensemble pour faire passer un message
que quelqu'un m'a dit de faire passer il
faut que j'essaie d'avoir des
statistiques sont à la hauteur du prix
que pour lequel je payais pour faire de
la fin des crédits salifou qui s'était
mis mon nom mais je veille après je te
laisse venir mais ça c'est fou quand
même pas ce que je dis c'est mettons y
cette compagnie l'oeil puis c'est
correct parce qu on le fait mais aussi
je lis des fêtes le gers les produits
locaux miel et produits comme c'est le
fun des fois aussi comme je comprends
quand ça devient un travail le thé mais
mettons si jean-louis ici coop tellement
mettons le prix de leur pub de leur
contrôle ils prennent soin puis disent
oui le sac fais comme ton affaire pim et
trans am by et tout le temps pas du
temps comme l'air triste
oui mais dont le juge ait pas donné un
le meilleur exemple parce qu'ils nous
baladent j'adore mairie ça parce que je
cours de toute façon parce que tout ce
qui me demande de faire je le fais toute
façon pis je cours ex essuyé le n 8
s'est fixé c'est vraiment mais mettons
un shampooing pour pour les cheveux et
ios que
parce que j'utiliserai shampoing là je
ne sais pas si je suis heureux sur un
point le dossier mais là il faut que je
fasse comme steve meyer shampoing
j'utilise ma vie tpiy peas mais c'est
sain et sauf qu'après ses excuses moi
finir céder là c'est pour revenir sur
sur la raison pour laquelle je pense
c'est devenu sérieux c'est qu'après ce
mois ci à quelqu'un qui me cale sur
seulles ouais en fait un peu chier parce
que c'est quand même c'est un peu ma job
pis si tu es petit tu comprends pas que
cet aspect là c'est comme si je t'écoute
est la télé puis en deux dans une
enseigne mr tu voyais guillaume lemay
thivierge qui relance à youndé voit pas
quand les guillaume lemay thivierge
il ya eu 10 jo comédie y mettons les
chanteurs céline dion la commune font
une ridelle au bye bye comme une
fonderie de la page pour ce faire il
normal dans l'oeil du public sur ce
métier là qu'on rit toi ça c'est sûr que
quand ils deviennent non c'est que l'on
en fait la même chose c'est la même
chose et c'est un chose
l'expérience et quand ils voient la pub
derbali sens à ce que la fille a joué sa
douche shampoing +6 une actrice qui est
payé pour être l'hôte russie qui est ici
tout se vendre la forêt les influenceurs
défaut les pubs sont plus camoufler
peut-être où ça passe à la nature et à
brême source de produits halal à naples
c'est comme un espèce de peu par la
bonté mais là maintenant et un choix de
m ce mais n'empêche que c'est comme
entendons personnel tpo comme un
personnage et exogènes pub qui vend
quelque chose sauf que si tu prends la
décision de vendre ce produit là de
faire ses choix de vie qui devient ton
métier fo cotation dans le sang ce qui
évidemment me dérange ou dans 1
le chalet le thé j'assume que les gens
fassent comme vache à lait c'est au wac
genre les jeunes ont chanté comme sam
c'est normal que qui a des gens qui
aiment poster puisqu'elle va toujours
avoir des gens que pour rire ou pour se
moquer ou pourrait faire des jokes là
dessus ou pourrait même et je pense que
en tant qu' influenceurs comme tu dis
s'est rendu m et ips et c'est vrai c'est
sérieux c'est je le conçois tu aimais me
rappelle plus qui récemment écrit genre
c'est difficile comme métier il faut
qu'on pense des vidéos vous qu'on fasse
nos recherches faut qu'on fasse des pubs
comme messi ta job
quelqu'un moi honnêtement je suis loin
d'être celui qui est le plus sollicité
mais honnêtement quelqu'un qui met plus
que 35 heures dans ce seul je sais pas
comment tu fais pour gérer cela fort ces
jours ci je comprends pas je comprends
pas comment tu peux pas c'est plus que
35 heures même si tu veux faire un post
à chaque jour avec des story pts tu
comprends pas comment tu peux mettre
plus que 35 heures dont sur tandis que
nantes avoir la scam et jusqu'à 35 ha
ben si tu enlèves tout ce qui est
procrastination jour les son fils depuis
répondre aux commentaires non c'est
parce qu'il s'est offert un pot ça donne
aussi éditer la couleur de leurs photos
cru que ça peut leur prendre quatre le
thé comme puis en fait c'est que si
c'est ta job mais 70 ans non mais c'est
ça mon point le ski je te dirais que les
35 heures c'est admettons que des
passages derrière du monde qui qui font
leur job à tout les jours 50 heures des
travailleurs autonomes y en a plein les
faits exacts c'est une job c'est un
travail c'est le travail choisi de
prendre si le temps que ça apprendre
c'est normal soit exact c'est normal que
des gens qui aiment possible si nos mac
et des gens qui aient dix opinions là
dessus plus énorme tout seuil normal
explique ce qu'omet pour trouver phone
un peu puis des retrouver un peu d'élus
du disque que lui disent ils
sauf qu'il faut que le mot influenceurs
est vraiment galvaudé mais je suis au
tricot la définition exacte ne trouve
que les andes est une personnalité du
web de l' affaire c'est que c'est pas ce
que je fais franchement tu pas c'est pas
mon travail c'est une conséquence à ce
que j'avais guillaume lemay thivierge
il vendait ses produits est ce que c'est
un influenceur parce qu'ils influencent
les gens achetaient des noms et quad
c'est quoi la différence que dans le
fond des personnalités publiques de
cécile hartmann qui faisaient des
peuples et fédé peu pour maxi en faisait
pour en deux c'est quoi la différence
entre mon arrière qui s'en occupe ici
pour simplifier des peuples à se dire
alors voici ma nouvelle crème que
j'adore je l'utilisé tout le monde me
demande qu'est-ce que je mène à mon visa
tout le monde
vous êtes de plus en plus de mettre
mardi na na nana na na ce que j'ai
commencé à faire c'est quand je reçois
des messages à plat je me fais souvent
demandé je prenais screenshot des
questions auxquelles je me suis demandée
pour les mots par rapport à toute cette
histoire le trop chaude prince alois sa
première chose qui m'est on cite sans
dévaloriser quoi que ce soit aussi
certaines personnes pensent qu est ce
que tu fais pas valide
moi personnellement je suis pas d'accord
je trouve que tu as un talent à qui
jugeraient que j'irais jusqu'à dire
exceptionnelle qui est différent de
dorothée non mais non mais tu t'es tu
étais peut-être pas une comédienne nous
tu étais peut-être porter mais quelqu'un
qui construit quelque chose puis qu'un
talent dans le fixe et des gens qui
s'intéressent à toi parce que tu fais
puis la faire c'est que pourquoi je me
sens des valeurs
ce n'est pas de leur faute c'est de ma
faute cdc des pointes qui vont atteindre
+ team étant quelqu'un commence ma venue
est peu
lun à jeu carte supporte plus de voir
quelqu'un se dit que c'est qu'ils
viennent d'un même c'est parce que c'est
des gens qui me fascine parce que je
mets non c'est plus sain à faire de moi
même j'ai des doutes
comme si tu pertinence que je fais et je
sais que ça le spo négatif ce que je
fais c'est positif la majorité du temps
mais je me demande souvent si ce que je
fais et pertinents puis c'est une
question que le monde sont comme sérieux
pourquoi vous la suivez genci pas
intéressant ce qu'a dit alors rien à
dire de c'est sûr que ça matin parce que
je le dis pense mon cij le thé fait qu
scission qui quand je vois se passer
c'est que c'est bon bon point à 1.264 10
et qui disent il ya plein de monde qui
m'accusent de débouler un goût de thé
l'intimidation despatie nation au début
dit moi je fais juste pour rire type
c'est pas méchant pis c'est juste pour
ramener un côté ludique est inférieur à
10 j'ai l'impression qu'on se prend
sparrow sérieuses internet où tu es
sérieux juste pas des jobs pyrénées puis
mes tantes et kata le alloti écrit les
affaires en ph adamo petit adam ou deux
fois il répondait une joke pilote est
comme ça hop et c'est comment on rit t
il
je sais que tu connais pas la personne
des fois tu sais pas l'intention se
situe parce que vraiment avec piqué ou
six parce que c'est juste une blague
cela mais mettons regarder ces affaires
puis je me suis dit que c'est quelque
chose qu'elle dit a dit que qui est moi
qui disais à telle personne n'est
vraiment pas content et vraiment flux
que tu l'a imité
quel était le genre je sais même pas ce
que faisait après mais je sais pour
fouiller dans les affaires de me parler
d'elle parce que c'est venu
c'est venu sur le fait qu'il était au
pot de quatre mois se soumet ses rôles
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit ce que je
pensais pas à errer spécifiquement le
beau je pense à personne en particulier
avec un que j'ai dit tout ce que j'avais
personnes en panne
c'est vraiment un enfer de en général le
show-business au québec qui autre que ce
soit des humoristes
que ce soient des acteurs des chanteurs
aux rêveurs qui sont autant qu'ils n'ont
pas envie d'être le web qu'on pense
d'eux se montre de se mettre en scène
semail un préjugé puis je le comprends
dans le sens que c'est d'autres
confessent et on ouvre notre caméra
rongeurs spirit et outils noon ou nounou
qu'on fait tout le pij comprend d'où ça
vient
c'est juste ça peut être blessant si tu
parle de quelque chose que tu connais
pas ils nous connaissent pas tant que ça
ils vont pas en profondeur arrivons avec
les red wings qui vont voir jean paul
baudouin utilisez une carte cadeau ça
allait plus loin puis comprend ce que
c'est mais 4 à sa défense est allé plus
loin pied était très nuancée pas pas
cette histoire le précise au moins j'ai
vu le 3e troisième point que je le dire
c'est justement ce fameux terme
influenceurs le temps puis on apparaît
justement le podcast tant qu'à moitié le
fait d'être influenceurs cpo d'époque
connu parce que tu influenceurs et
influence parce que c'est une
personnalité web qui est devenu connu kg
td contre ce médecin
c'est quoi la différence entre toi je te
ment ou qui payons les divers joue comme
et xavier dolan qui les représentants de
louis mouton je peux quelle compagnie
ouïe fait des films mais il devenu connu
puis montez connu bel olivier parole
pour situer un peu pour sauter là au
delà de ce qu'on dit claes un
influenceur s'est dernièrement il signé
un contrat avec un alcool fort c'est
bien contre une publicité sur instagram
loud c'est loin et si je pense qu'on va
appeler influenceurs la personne que
c'est dur de dire est qu'ils se penchent
en temps ce pot un acte ans pau mais tu
crées du contenu petit fait du
divertissement alfonso ruiz je pense que
ce qui fait en sorte que en fait je
pense pas aussi sur le fait qu'il ya
beaucoup de jugement par rapport à ça
c'est le mieux pour être un influenceur
ceux qui parlent de toi que tout montre
toi que tu sais tout s'est si sur chaque
personne influenceurs rien d'autre de
connexité je n'ai pas de définir pas
les musiques qui sort c'est juste je
pense qu'il devrait avoir un autre terme
pour les apps nous appeler je m'inclus
parce que ce poste confirme on veut pas
nécessairement influencer le monde
ce qu'on veut c'est partager nos vies je
pense qu on a tout différent des
différents motifs
m différentes motivations mais c'est une
façon de capable de vivre de ce que tu
fais c'est juste pas les publicités le
monde par équipes qui comptent nul c'est
sa serviette ou jouera seul c'est comme
si si le temps que tu passes par exemple
sur youtube ou sur à entretenir la
communauté sur instagram
s'il fallait que ce temps leur soit
jamais rémunéré et aurait pas le choix
de faire payer au fait j'oubliais j'ai
vu des la médecine ou non mais si on met
les podcasts sont taxe est accessible à
tout le monde
graphiquement soyaux tôt sur les
applications balado mais ça coûte pas
rien passé je sais on n'a pas le choix
dans un sens ou sinon vous reste à bonne
spirale
le conte à bulles mais non mais c'est ce
métier et tout les modèles rien ne
change et l argent comment ça fonctionne
c'est fait les grosses boîtes qui avait
bondi pouvoir de l'argent à certaines
époques y en a encore mais qui voyais
les gens migrer vers le web pour toutes
ces personnalités parents des modèles
changent il faut trouver de nouvelles
sources de revenus ces épices et sopi
dans vies toutes les peaux gratis mais
on est habitué d'abord la musique grâce
à des contenus youtube gratis tout
gratis mais dans la vie ça coûte pour
rien à faire il faut faire des pubs des
rudes et c'est ça la réalité peut-être
des fois le monde jean est pas un peuple
c'est pas 4 mais oui mais crise sinon il
n'y aurait pas de pagaille à 15 secondes
achakzai minutes coller ce mois béni oui
oui même moi sur mon bras the web
j'ai hâte bloc je vois jamais aucune
équipe est facile pour s'attacher genre
spoiler depuis dans l'odet hat de las
parce que ça nous ait pas fait plaisir
charlie sérieux dans notre blog pire de
marché avez-vous expérimenté avec bagdad
rock vous moi j'ai fait une faute de lsd
ma vie dit sujet la dose c'était quoi
ton très tôt dans la faune c'est ce qui
coûte à la maison aussi votre acompte et
qui met le ca fait ça fait longtemps je
pensais fait cinq-six sa jeune amie qui
libanais puis on est allé voir mon frère
de semaine au liban on arrivé le 31
décembre au soir
on restait du x men qui mon ami et
musique mon frère pinault a mis le 31
août c'est pour la nouvelle année pour
une habitude tradition en fait la cité
faites le moi même j'avais 22 rue pie
jamais fait jamais fait ça jamais fait
de moche même j'en fumais du parc à
s'informer de marx dans ma vie
petit plus d'innover pour l'essayer man
was not one note c'est un gars qui fait
que j'ai confiance les mâcon vient et
étalages fais pas confiance à ce gala je
sais qu'ici fait ce et fait ses
recherches ce un intellectuel seconde
incroyable je sais que pendant bartz et
ce fake je te le fais pas pour faire
elle partait plan est côlon avec non
vraiment contrôler parce que c'est un
eagle plus intéressant que je connais
c'est vraiment un stade c'est celui ci
fait ce pour l'expérience psychique
menkes un petit rituel spirituel
à clermont on a rien à terre une
interview lieberman le 31 à 7 heures du
soir
la barque dans un autre domaine puis on
monte puis on roule
puis les libertés se bat là mr annette
effect comme la côte pile beyrouth puis
livré sa cote a précédé montagne gros
gros haute montagne
en porc aux rôles sont dans un petit
chalet mais dans le fond des montagnes
la plus belle vue que veux tu as vite tu
vois toutes les montagnes ses démons en
egypte c'est incroyable l'accord entre
la pile qui gagnent des libanais mène à
minuit on se pose pas guéri cap
d'antibes alain py cadastre hasardeux
buzz c'est parti à tacler une heure plus
tard c'est le christ ça va arriver ça me
quitte plus tard chienne à quatre pattes
sur galette cap humaine
je trouve triste mousse tellement
incroyable petit détail que la pression
est normale et on avait tout misé on
avait toutes les télés blacklight
pigeons les ai faits dans l'anti veille
du sommet on y est on avait une
application sur l'ipad même que comme
tout bouge plus ça fait comme une espèce
de form factor avec des couleurs le moi
de mon frère des lieux qui ont tiqué
sopi elle te tue son petit fils au pied
mais c'est comme si j'avais compris des
enfants ce soit là mais c'est comme si
j'avais débloquer quelque chose que
j'avais jamais vu avant plus je le
voyais comme c'est comme jeter en
connexion avec l'univers les étoiles
toute l'équipe mendy ses complices de
son horloge me disait j'avais la
lucidité de me dire demain
karaboué doit être fini tu veux trouver
que tes réflexions en ce moment puisque
te compris le sens mais je me disais
tout pas de sens non je me dit vous êtes
vous retrouvé qu'ont eu ces réflexions
le dessus écrit par la cpi qui
plongerait les yeux parce que je me suis
jeune je me suis pas exactement
je me souviens certaines réflexions
certains trucs piste ali diplôme
philosophie claire
jomby étoiles puis puis je me disais la
même voie où tu vas perdre un petit peu
ce mets l'eau en ce moment je me suis
dit si tu as compris si l'auto raison
notament être repu raison c'est que je
me disais c'est lui qui a raison
je ne sais pas mais c'était vraiment
beau
ça a duré toute la nuit une partie
marcher dans la montagne montant jusqu
en haut avec la musique si c'est pour
faire plus je pensais de stimuli
sensoriels nous sommes absolument espace
des musiques épiques mène on monte en
montagne même chiche
le croyant le seigneur des anneaux pas
dans la nature
j'ai adoré ça pitt et apprécié je pense
que c'est une question de le faire avec
les bonnes personnes au bon moment la
bonne place et jamin et elle jamais mais
j'ai vraiment de mots sujet g j'ai
commencé à en faire un petit peu de
votre temps en temps peep-toe dos maco
racing mois puis de d'apprendre succès
quoique ça fait chimiques mali puis
libérés sauf c'est parce qu on est tous
que tout le monde nous dit où c'est la
société de nous mais des restrictions
sur plaine à farah dans la façon paon
spi et igo ton ego est vraiment forte et
je trouve que lsd enlève tout ton égo et
on dirait qu'ils sont effectivement puis
écouter de la musique mais je passe tout
écouter de la musique est magnifique tu
attends tout libre son tt même ta vision
sur ces choses auraient regardé la ramq
et le la date qui est lourde pour elle a
regardé pendant une heure puis voir
l'énergie des tenues incroyables et mis
à fond dedans
dans les petites lignes tu vas en temps
voir l'univers même pied
c'est comme tout se connectent comme si
tout se connecter c'est vrai mais c'est
faux
trente secondes tu clames end prochain
il ya de la beauté là dedans il ya des
parkings ya un mouchoir ce qu'elle est
marginale bois je pense qu'il ya
certaines choses qui qu'il fait pas le
métier l'énergie ça existe l'énergie je
crois vraiment l'énergie
puis quand on regarde effectivement sur
la liste des du bois ou des 18 mètres
marque là c'est comme si toute essence
était décuplée
moi j'ai fait de la miss fait de la
méditation sur nous sur les idées des
fois pis c c'est vraiment intense et
magique
mais encore une fois c'est faux faux
faux le faire intelligemment et je veux
moi c'est plus ou surtout s'il tiff
citadine à toi jeune athlète non c'est
clair mais c'est une
c'est dommage que ça a été mal vu dans
les années quoi 60 tandis que les études
parce qu'ils ont fait des grosses études
là dessus mais longtemps puis ils ont
mis comme 8x insisté garde puis les 800
scientifiques lyon il y avait il y avait
des problèmes que ça faisait des années
qu'ils étaient capables de régler les
problèmes scientifiques puis en 2007 on
avait tout réglé leur problème
croyant marais parce que de bandjoun
l'anglais soyouz juste tu avais pas peur
d'essayer des trucs un peu papa dalila
dans la pensée fait d'aller et anémone
et de newark de recul temps passe rien
on dit je pense que un jour je souhaite
vraiment qui on le voit déjà avec le big
one
c'est magnifique ce que ça fait je
trouve que le peuple rouge pas quelqu'un
qui fait vraiment du patch faut de temps
en temps je suis ça m'amène pas grand
chose en commun accord simple je trouve
que l'alcool c'est là c'est la pirogue
sur la planète avec les cigarettes mais
sa quête d'alex je souhaite qu'un jour
puis on le voit avec colorado motion
génère digoin et j'aimerais c'est que la
descente ou que les gens peuvent aller
un labo puisse s'installer pour une fin
de semaine en sécurité et en sécurité
je remettrai est exact que les gens
parce que oui parce qu'on est plus bas
que le monde sont en train d'un peu de
vie virer fou pis ça ferait ça ferait du
bien je pense d'eux ça nous aide comme
ralentir la vie 30 secondes de process
banshee et après ce bain dans le dos au
thorax puis tout le monde se pose à
chaque jour chaque semaine chaque mois
cette fois de temps en temps un petit
oui ça serait ça serait vraiment positif
sourd sur les gens
[Musique]
bernard laval et merci d'être ici
d merci pour l'invitation oui comme tu
disais avant qu'on commence à tourner de
te croyais que tu étais en vacances
encore non mais aujourd'hui c'est
officiellement tout me va comme moi
j'avais le droit de travailler mais
intervenue plus tôt un petit peu à cause
de la nouvelle du du guide alimentaire
canadien puis c'est sûr que on va en
parler parce qu'il est intéressant quand
même les changements qui sont apportées
par le nouveau guide canadien en fait
qui va sortir éventuellement on ignore
qu'un mais dont on sait les grandes
lignes dans le fond - ouais pour rester
comme la grosse nouvelle dans mon milieu
comme un brunch examine tout sauf une
semaine puis la première chose c'est
comme une bonne année une année est rien
d'autre avancer parce que pour nous
c'est comme la grosse nouvelle puisque
pendant des années que vous l'attendez
aussi le cas dans la version comme
actuellement tant qu on fait comme si
t'es pas encore arrivée laisse la
version actuelle date de 2007 mais ça
fait longtemps
si moi j'ai commencé à étudier si on
était déjà là
moi c'est le seul que j'ai connu dans ma
carrière donc oui ça fait longtemps
qu'il va piller tête ainsi que des
modifications j'ai lu ton ton livre
paraît dernier l'autre avoir été mouche
à la fois tu dis dans le prochain guide
c'est hyper l'an 2015 je pense qu'on lit
on sait déjà qui est une la tarte mais
oui non mais c'est sûr parce que de
toute façon on savait qu'ils allaient
avoir une thune refondu kinect c'était
attendu mais déjà en 2016 si je me
trompe peut-être mais en 2015
on savait qu'ils avaient quelque chose
qui s'en venait puis aux états unis us à
chaque cinq ans qu'ils vont faire voir
modifications nous on ne peut dans la
réglementation donc on devra chaque tant
d'années on doit faire la modification
nos états unis c'est chaque cinq ans et
comme en 2015 des états unis ont eu
leurs un nouveau guide
je m'étais base un peu là dessus pour
voir si le premier parce que
en fait on prend il revenait métier
l'environnement par le passé faisait pas
partie des recommandations a dit le
guide c'est comme quoi manger pour être
en santé pour les humains point final
mais le moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on
voit de façon plus globale fait que plus
se retire on est vraiment dans cette
mouvance lance moment qui mettons tout
impressionné les grandes lignes des sig
et de l'eau est-ce que tu étais encore
tout ce qui est là est ce qui était
critiqué sais quoi mais ton opinion là
dessus mais là celui qui met tant la
version 2007 pas encore la version qui
est officiel on a eu des grosses
critiques qui avaient c'était grosso
modo 1
comme je disais qu'on ne s'attaque à la
santé humaine on compense pas plus loin
plus larges comme étant l'environnement
que je pense que c'est ce procès de 2007
a maintenant et il ya eu une grosse
mouvance sociétaires par rapport à
l'environnement laiteries sur tout juste
maintenant des deux des deux trois
dernières années j'ai entendu un énorme
excès de fermer les yeux sur ce way
exactement sauf que c'est un changement
qu'ils ont fuit le titre mais toi la
place le ton du gouvernement parce que
c'est très comme rigide comme
structurant gouvernement fait maintenant
à leur place que si comme dans un guide
c'est comme ce qu'on a toujours fait ça
puis on doit continuer de cette façon là
people et loeb y en aura qui sont là
pour dire si c'est que s'est passé aux
états unis
quant aux en 2015 quand ils ont voulu
intégrer l'environnement dans les
recommandations du guide en dix ans mais
maintenant on se rend compte que est en
train de détruire la planète faut qu'on
y pense puis la façon dont on mange ça
peut avoir une influence avec peut-être
qu'ils sont recommande le donne des
recommandations à la population faut pas
juste penser à la santé d'aujourd'hui
faut penser à la santé des prochaines
générations que ça passe en préservant
l'environnement
en gros c'est cela que quand ils ont
sorti une espèce de deux rapports
préliminaires avant qu'ils sortent ils
ont dit comme et voici qu'est ce qu'on
suggère bla bla bla y avait un chapitre
complet sur l'environnement sur le fait
qu'on aurait consommé moins de viande
parce que ça pourrait avoir un impact
positif sur la planète le blabla tout ce
qu'il foule de leurs bilans disponibles
les lettres qui ont été envoyées les
rencontres qui ont été faits les
soudeurs
oui c'est relativement facile à accéder
parce que ça fait partie des documents
publics puis donc les
ces ateliers eu beaucoup de la bi puis
quand le nouveau guide des sorties y
avait pas une seule fois le mot
environnement à remplir absolument ils
ont pas du tout recommandé de diminuer
la consommation de viande en partie à
cause des lobbys qui l'argument qui
était sorti c'est celui que je ne vous
dire c'est de dire non non non un guide
alimentaire c'est pour la santé restent
et puis 10e et en lettonie 7e capable de
parler d'autre chose que de nutrition
fait qu'il ya ce que vous connaissez
vous connaissez pas les trucs
d'environnement avec parlez-en peuple
changeait pas ça fait que c'est un peu
pour discréditer finalement le messager
pour que le message passe pas par avoir
mais c'est fou mais temps quand tu quand
tu considères que des lobbys comme ça
peuvent faire peuvent altérer
littéralement l'histoire des jeux durent
six admettons que le step et pris 10 ans
valls a fait une large différence sur
l'impact que c'est le attelages le train
sur dix ans la consommation de viande
avait déjà jusque là en ce moment on
s'entend que c'est
c'est en mouvance lettier le moose passe
puis la consommation de viande et et vue
très différents
différemment coeuve le disant par
exemple mais de savoir que d'un jeu de
lober modifier notre perception le
dessus pendant longtemps cessé
c'est frustrant pour monsieur madame
tout le monde puis pour moi aussi si une
partie de mon deuxième lit je te monde
n'en valait pas tout ce qu'on vous dit
fait l'historique un peu de co2 comme un
certain lobby ont réussi à modifier des
recommandations nutritionnelles ou même
des croyances qu'on a bien l'exemple que
donne parce que au canada n'ont pas de
temps d'historique que ce sapin était
comme répertoriés mais aux états unis
vraiment plus ni pile exemple que je
donne 6 par rapport à l'industrie du
sucre
grosso modo dans les années genre 64 70
80 personnes ont commencé à voir comme
il ya plus de maladies du coeur on sait
pas trop d'où ça provient qu'est ce qui
se passe dans la blanc puis avec comme
deux écoles de pensée que s'affrontaient
une école de pensée qui disait c'est les
gras saturés qui sont moins mauvais qu
une école de pensée qui disent et de
sucre qui est le mauvais et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est que l'industrie du
sucre comme elle avait peur de ce
message là de dire le succès pas bon on
fait tout pour manger ils ont donné de
l'argent ils ont financé plein pépin
d'études
sur les gras saturés exemple ici tous
les chercheurs qui s'intéressent à 110
ans si on vous donne l'argent qu'on vous
donne de l'argent pour faire la pub pour
faire mais regardez de l'autre côté
eiffel
on veut juste regarder du côté des gras
saturés en cas de repos du côté du sud
et c'est ce qui s'est passé exactement
nation gouvernementales sont devenus
attention au gras saturés attention
grâce c'est le gros méchant dans notre
alimentation c'est le gratin s'entassent
intentions on ne peut pas parler du
sucre mais c'est parce qu'il ya eu des
lobbys en arrière qui ont donné un porte
voix à ces chercheurs là pour qu'on
parle juste dégraissage du rip qu'on en
oublie cela coûtait piste n'est pas
nécessairement en plus de commandes il
explique c'est pas de cacher les études
par rapport au succès juste de financer
les études seront utiles s'entend très
bien que les résultats de ces études là
à la haine négative c'est à l'aide des
études qui était catégorique sur le le
gras saturés exactement parce que le
chercheur mettons un des chercheurs qui
finançait ses seins socis impie ce
chercheur le lui sa catégorie stay
baisser les graisses saturées sais je
sais qu'ils regardaient les qu'ils ont
pas fait défaut aux études qui sont au
rsa mais ils ont donné de l'argent à
celui qui faisait des études qui
allaient dans le sens qu'ils voulaient
en finale
je passe te lèves calais ce manteau à
chaque stand toyota se lever à 6h puis à
tolède à 5h à m'a jeté 1,5 un taxi pour
le commun des mortels mettons pour moi
c'est mes tongs en plus qu'à une vie
plutôt nocturne en général c'est comme
c'est comme impensable mais lyon mais a
en même temps une certaine époque quand
je mangeais bh on le faisait si c'était
possible
c'est beaucoup de monde qu'un qui vont
cégep lille se lève vraiment aux
fonctions à l'école pour huit mois il
faut que j'élève à ce hold up ils font
peu précieux dont une job de 20 heures
par semaine et s'en vont travailler
après ce faux qui étudie le fond tout
ouais je pensais pas une question de ton
énergie et la magentis dimanche parce
que qu'est-ce que monstro comme c'est
d'avoir une énergie constante toute la
journée
ouais ouais parce que quand lève à 5h
site off de pas loin crash et la petite
fatigue d'après midi c'est en temps des
farines stressé mais c'est normal ce
pétrole à corps humain est fait entre 2h
et 3h temps commence à presser un petit
peu de mélatonine
c'est fait pour l'oeil est beaucoup
développée par rapport à société je les
fais jamais ça fait un petit boulot j'en
ai pas faire pourquoi j'espère que
l'énergie puis je me sens pas le besoin
d'enfants
[Musique]
mais ce que j'ai à dire c'est que
un questionnement un peu le scientifique
par rapport à ce qu'on l'ait fait pour
faire une nuit de sommeil dans divers
genres la siesta
trois mois après midi puis même du
montreur bureau six mois deux heures je
te vois tu es vraiment fait qu'il ait
jamais mis de faciès doivent être un peu
sportif qui a des façons de faire des
sciences et des façons en tunisie on ne
sont pas capables juste dormir ou de
s'endormir rapidement moi je m'endors le
gîte l'est ça me prend
c'est beaucoup par la respiration chez
des respects puis je m'endors m us est
un truc de fou la 4e année pataky son
genre précis j'étais moche et que tu
poses tc citons ensuite en ring si tu
passes tes stades de sommeil puis c'est
moi et ma montre a fait un peu la même
chose le sais un petit peu moins précis
mais je peux comparer mes stats avec
l'ethiopie
et aucune façon que je puisse rivaliser
avec toi en termes d'énergie parce que
mon sommeil et ne lâchait spécialité des
stars mon sommeil statistiquement par là
ils ne lâchent et combattit moitié mais
c'est que je travaille je pense là une
des choses qu'ils ont pour se renforcer
notre vie à dormir
ouais je te faisais quand je me lève ou
des petites lèvres sans voir la cafetera
besoin d'énergie ouais
c'est pas normal un type sympa
granby sentent frustrés ou un moment
dieu vous je m'élève aller travailler
je dois tu dois une envie c'est vrai tu
prêt et capable d'aller vivre l'est en
amazonie les gens capables de ceux ci
nous a pas que manger c'est pour toi
l'huma ya un potentiel infini
putschistes le relooking en place qu'on
peut devenir ce qu'on veut en ville si
oui juste attention je me suis
maintenant mon histoire parfois que ce
que j'ai accompli ses propos brayauds
peu importe mais ces genres garden à
saint-eustache et nuls mais ne la
négligent dégueulasse je resterai là
comme andy mcdonald le bingo et hamid
jpy au scandale ouais c'est comme des
genres mais je dois fleuriste et comme
elle est
[Musique]
rendu l'âme à joris même pas franchi
récemment à cause de mon passé je n'ai
pas dit si vous faut-il les faits que
j'ai commencé tout seul à posséder vidéo
puis on est capable de gagner mais trop
longtemps la bonne équipe quand je dis
d'abonnés c'est pas par rapport à ce
peuple là pour le travail qu'il a
contenu puis d'abord du monde qui
consomment des contenus pour si oui le
conduit cap qu'ils prennent pour la paix
dans l'invité une différence de juste
donné un laïc mais quelqu'un qui suit
qu'est ce que tu veux montrer au monde
est vraiment une grosse école mais bref
que tout est possible tout est possible
puis mettons juste backtrack est un
petit peu parce que ça me fascine
crissement au niveau du sommeil année je
l'avais écrit après avoir vu et avait
posté ce test jugeant gens venaient
police était comme esthétique 95% de
sommeil de qualité de sommeil avec
classement du dossier
moi je comprenais rien mais j'ai vu que
j'étais genre je me dis ah steeman ce
genre où que je sois meilleur à ce poste
avec risha les mêmes qu'est ce que tu
fais puis tu m'as donné de zafour tu
m'avais dit pas de wade en chambre ce
qui ça et semble être une idée géniale
et on sait le grand pas dans la chambre
qu'il laisse maintenant accusé ces dames
à schmitten avion dans ma prochaine
maison ma maison va tout en béton pour
ma chambre ce béton qui doit voir un
seul mot qui dans ce genre pas dedans
doit pas tomber
0e parce que c'est stressant pour moi
même temps quand tu te réveilles
je m'étends moment c'est les souris sur
la table de chevet quand je me réveille
j'ai instinctivement l'envi de checker
puis aussitôt double écran sais pas quoi
regarder matin ce potentiel dans le fond
non mais ça va être mon téléphone
au début quand je commence à me livrer
en plus tôt fallait je les mets dans une
autre pièce pour avoir enlevé puis
j'adore l'équipe l'on finit un peu
beaucoup de choses qui a été nominé
fucking stupide puis
je pense crédit on est vraiment à des
caprices chose qui est sérieux c'est
qu'on n'est pas capable de faire des
choses qu'il faut y aller un peu le
conquérir
samedi matin à 90 pièces plutôt que de
me lever pour y aller fermer mais là
maintenant j'ai juste à côté des moteurs
de chez rim est tout le temps malade les
joueurs des hawks nous mettrons sinus
congestionné a quitté un matin juste
nous ips mais si je mens je vais
attendre un peu plus parce qu'ils font
mais même dans ton sommeil le en santé
entre les dix minutes nous à chaque fois
ses potes grâce à make it right parfois
non non c'est ce qu'ont fait que m'avait
dit le téléphone puis les lunettes
bleues - pour bloquer la lumière bleue
c'est des lunettes que toi te bats cd
vraiment voir qui est créé pour bloquer
les quatre hommes étaient avant tout que
j'aime et tenter ce laptop d'hadrons
leed for laptops se couche à ces gens-là
pires affres des lunettes bleues base
acceptable la lumière là dessus
qu'est ce qui arrive dans le fond c'est
que note notre corps qui commence à
faire un droit on est fait pour cette
ville est sale et méchant terme dans des
pays comme le canada ou la corse aussi
un regard des fonctions d
parce qu'on a pas d'exposition savez dit
c'est pas ma soeur a principalement on
manque vraiment de tout notamment d'être
au pied
oui on aurait en pôles d'exposition
soleil puis c'est l'idéal c'est pendant
l'été c'est comme ça il va te
transformer ce décès comme un peu de
l'énergie de la photosynthèse
bref attendons une exposition au soleil
en se levant puis c'est ce qu'on appelle
un besoin ici au canada fx pour ce que
moi maintenant je veux supplémenté de
lifestyle mais il est délicat pour les
décès lui ai fait je concède le matin de
sa mort et d'avoir plus d'énergie si tu
vu que j'ai pas d'exposition série alors
je pense que je me fasse un petit peu
tâche posséder une langue qui est fait
pour se mêler bonne liste une pochette
les ballons plus yannick plus inquiets
de l'énergie mais si ça fait que notre
corps on se lève avec le soleil puis on
se couche et le soleil la fois que cyril
s'est admirablement identifier le corps
fait pas nécessairement là la
distinction entre sam et couper nos
côtes sont mes laténium si vous savez
pas ce que la mélatonine c'est votre
corps est précieux pour vous aider à
vous relaxer à vous endormez pousse à
vous il demandera peut aller se coucher
jusqu à chaussy fille jade en un peu
commun afin qu'ils travaillent fact
qu'est-ce qui lé plus les râper les plus
lourds mettant exemple un quart des gros
rapport à se coucher c'est pas l'idéal
de manger deux armes a tendance à
coucher de quoi deux groupes se livrent
manger quoi je savais ce que je veux
plus légers puis ça ça va des chocs 25
miss moi j'étais trop le fait que
l'activité physique ou six étaient pour
pour être fatigué le soir puis avoir un
bon saut mais je pense que ces principes
mais tais-toi pourtant cette année j'ai
toujours j'ai toujours toujours toujours
été un j'ai toujours eu un cheminement
tout le monde fuit jamais été capable de
bien dormi ces méthodes pour que je
dorme bien projet les conditions
parfaites ça ça me fait vraiment chier
ces moyens sont je me réveille exemple
mais cette conversation la même c'est
pas défaitiste
en ce moment je suis en train d'essayer
de travailler sur moi même à à force
d'écouter justement des podcasts comme
goggins c'est me dire chris mayne faut
que je m'améliore tiff
aucune famille opi trop longtemps
maintenant dans la vie je visais pas la
meilleure action personnelle sénat la
majorité du monde c'est comme ça aussi
c'est que je suis le flou non mais je
dois mettant un terme est tombé dans le
sport mais pas dans toutes les femmes de
ta vie non c'est sa bête on jetait
complet sympa mais juste même poème
mettons à tout ce qui est l'écriture je
voulais me harir le sport le même
réflexe qu'était quantifiables pour moi
mais l'allemand l'amélioration la main
de ma personne et mon fonctionnement
humain je l'avais laissée de côté puis
de plus en plus je réalise que c'est sûr
que c'est quelque chose que je veux
vraiment mettre l'emphase mais souvent
je pense aussi que le monde il faut pas
s'affoler sur leur passion puisqu'il me
faut au moins sa focus vraiment juste là
dessus toi mais si ton cerveau il
fonctionne assez grand pour ça tout ça
va être plus soft
c'est la quantité d'or qui vous arrive
et laisse passer
mais mon sommeil optimale je me réveille
je me sens fraîche et d'énergie puis
tout nu mon alimentation tout l'espoir
de ma vie sont optimisés pour que je
sois performant fait qu'il ya beaucoup
d'études moutons qui sorte que le monde
qui dort plus que justement 6h30 à 7h
imart plus jeunes le jeudi pas accoster
dans pas parce qu'il donne c'est
notamment à cause de taux mais il ya
sûrement d'autres habitudes de vie qui
fait qu'ils acceptent le monde dans le
fond qui dorment six heures et demie
souvent toute leur vie et plus optimisée
qui ont une moins de 5000 sont plus en
santé général
je suis pas juste plus vite
mais ces bonnes ça m'inquiétait dont le
monde prenne ça dans mes huit heures
c'est bon c'est la vie dans le passé un
peu plus là dessus je dors son ennemi à
cette heure là présentement des trois
derniers mois m'ont arraché comme 16h41
ce que les plantes aussi un parcours
images ph faut je te le dise j'en
profite pour te dire que les plantes on
les a sous-estimé beaucoup est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle est plantes sont
130 sont quoi sont sans cesse qu'ils
ressentent conscients les émotions mais
les plantes n'aime pas les prédateurs
aussi un mois je vis les plantes n'aime
pas ça c'est sûr que nous on a toujours
regardé les plantes comme des espèces
figé dans la terre et qui végète
quand quelqu'un fait rien on dit vgg
producteurs mais aujourd'hui si tu
savais la quantité de choses qu'on
découvre sur les plans sur leur capacité
à se défendre sur leur tout les
alcaloïdes que les fentes les plantes
ont développé pour se protéger des gens
qui l'image
la caféine café caféine la théine ce
sont deux alcaloïdes qui ont été
développés par des plantes de la famille
du café pourquoi et pour tirer des
parasites pour tuer les parasites qui
les marchés nous on est l'espèce humaine
et dépendantes aux drogues développé par
les plans disais mais a beaucoup ce
qu'on appelle les huiles essentielles
c'est beaucoup des molécules qui ont été
développés par les plantes pour dire aux
animaux qui n'ont pas un rôle dans leur
cycle ne mangeait pas en parler on
parlait des piments forts là c'est la
même chose à la capsaïcine des piments
au début ça a été beaucoup pour
contrôler les micro-organismes c'est les
champignons les bactéries dans la
nourriture mais les mammifères qui nous
ont frôlé dans le cycle du piment ben
ils se font piquer par l'apathie
capsaïcine mais les oiseaux qui
disséminent les graines de cumin et qui
les font germer ailleurs cédé a mis du
piment un donc la capsaïcine ne touche
pas les oiseaux mais il n'oublie nous
automnale à la bouche mais jusqu'à
maintenant on a découvert que les plans
tout ce qu'on pensait exclusive aux
animaux quasiment existe chez les
plantes c'est juste en principe de
survie c'est pas compliqué
l'objectif c'est de perpétuité gêne
aussi en grande partie dans on a trouvé
même des plantes urd animaux qui tire
jde
une expérience qui a été fait en afrique
du sud ou en prenait des coups d'où le
coup du cndd clubs d'afrique du sud puis
le gars il voulait faire de l'élevage de
koudou puis donc qui les a mis dans un
enclos pis il y avait des acacias dans
l'enclos puis les coudes ou qu'on me
demande les acacias
il s'est rendu compte que les animaux
qui étaient dans l'enclos b mais glisse
et puis comme ça ils maigrissent vire de
la nourriture qui à un moment donné les
animaux sont morts puis là ils font des
contenus stomacaux pouvoir ce qui s'est
passé puis se rendre compte que les
feuilles d'acacia n'ont pas été vraiment
bien digérée par les animaux puissent
annuel qu'est ce qui se passe
et là paf en analysant les feuilles
d'acacia il se rend compte que les
feuilles d'acacia été très très
concentré en tanins toxiques et pourquoi
parce que les acacias
quand le coude ou manger l'acacia ici
l'acacia envoyer des informations aux
autres acacias dans la direction du vent
pour le dit préparez vous il ya des
prédateurs qui arrivent des broutards et
les autres acacias synthétiser des
tanins toxiques et les concentrés dans
leurs feuilles et ils ont tué les
animaux ça ça existe et plein d'autres
des plantes qui sont capables de
reconnaître des membres de leur famille
par les racines des grands mamans qui
partagent avec les petits petit en bas
des plantes qui sont capables d'avoir
une certain sens du 100 dos doit essayer
c'est fascinant et bien un livre qui a
été écrit par un physiologiste italien
qui s'appelle l'intelligence des plantes
c'est c'est quelque chose là la seule
différence maintenant parce que c'était
dit tantôt que les plantes ne pas être
mangé la seule différence avec les
animaux c'est que les animaux quand tu
leur prends 50% ils vont mourir si
quelqu'un venait la fuite coupe au
milieu sauf que les plantes ils peuvent
faire jusqu'à 90% de leur parti visite à
petit puis remettre serait ta pouces
et donc on peut leur en prendre quand
même là mais tu vois ce que c'est
c'est la première fois que j'entends ça
cc c'est fascinant qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait c'est en tant qu'humain et on
ne l'a on a un devoir moral parce qu'on
a la capacité de discerner la morale on
a cette capacité là qui est pas une
capacité qui quitte à tous les animaux
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on a ce
devoir là si on prend en considération
je te mentir au niveau des animaux si on
prend en considération qu'on n'a pas le
droit de co qui ont le droit de survivre
si on prend la consternation avec ce que
tu viennes isère que les plantes aussi
ont ce droit là dans la survie à la iron
le désir non je vais pas réagir
j'ai pas parlé de droit j'ai juste dit
en fait que intérêts a plongé le disons
que le besoin de se perpétuer
l'intérêt survie à la survie oui les
plantes ont sévi si on considère que
toutes ces espèces là que sur les
plantes d'animaux ont l'intérêt à
survivre et que nous on a un devoir
moral en tant que cani montmoreau qu'est
ce qu'on fait ben n'a pas abusé le bras
bandé de ça une chaîne alimentaire c'est
ça c'est chacun mange celui qui le
précède et devient la nourriture de
celui qui le suit et à la fin il reste
les super prédateur auquel personne ne
touche qu elle pas mais les super
prédateur ben généralement dans une
chaîne alimentaire y en a pas autant que
ceux qui sont en bas parce que sinon ce
serait une catastrophe
l'humain lui sert aux produits donc le
blog il est là c'est je veux dire
si on veut nourrir combien de milliards
dont les projections dans l'ue à harare
- il parlait de combien de chasseurs
cueilleurs il y avait sur la terre
jamais avoir la sédentarisation il ya
dix mille ans au néolithique
ces tests et des piscines on viendra
beaucoup le million il ya maintenant une
terre où tu as une population de super
prédateur n'est plus nécessairement
d'accord et c'est pas juste ça c'est que
le super prédateur en question c'est un
insatisfait il est flanqué d'une
génétique d'insatisfaction parce qu'un
ours polaires l' image du phoque primera
du fat icompta ya un tuyau phoques
marbrés oua et il sent pif de la grèce
puis le lendemain c'est la semaine
suivante il tient aux phoques marbrés
puissant plus d'être c'est ça l'humain
lui c'est ici et intertitres et il faut
tout vous toujours eu le souci il veut
manger du de la gazelle il veut manger
du poisson niveau magie du temps il va
essayer ça et ils vont ramasser le plus
possible c'est à dire que il jamais
satisfait même taille à 1 milliard et en
veut plus il y en a 7 7
le problème qu'on à l'espèce humaine
pour moi c'est ça c'est la génétique des
satisfactions on avoue tout le temps
tout en toute âme et on ramasse ma part
on ramasse la part des autres et on
emmagasine ça on emmagasine pour pouvoir
vivre y en a quatre qui ont pu vivre
mille ans c'est alors qu'ils ont une
espérance de vie de 60 hamas mais il y
en aura masse et 52 milliards et
continue à raser des forêts pour amasser
encore puis moi je pense que c'est là
qu'il faudrait travailler moi c'est
s'est désactivé
je sais pas comment préfère la génétique
d'insatisfaction de l'humain mais c'est
ça c'est la disparition des dinosaures
qui a permis aux enfers d'exploser donc
c'est la mort des dinosaures mais quand
tu regardes les plaques qui nous
nourrissent les plantes à fleurs les
plantes à fleurs aussi c'est pas ça pas
toujours été là
les forêts du carbonifère là c'était des
palettes des forêts peuplées par des
plantes qui n'étaient pas des plantes à
flacé les plantes à ouville nu et donc
c'est la disparition de ce plan à cause
d'un changement climatique qui a fait
que les plantes à fleurs sont ont
explosé les plantes à fleurs
contre on s est plainte des ports et du
carbonifère c'est eux qui nous ont donné
à peu près les gisements de gaz certains
la transformation de ces plantes mais
aussi des certains sédiments en milieu
marin a généré le pétrole qu'on exploite
aujourd'hui donc c'est la mort qui a
créé le pétrin c'est une hécatombe le
pétrole et le gaz les hydrocarbures
fossiles et il faut pas oublier ça quand
on les exploite faut pas l'oublier
et donc c'est ça qui a fait que les
plantes à fleurs qui ont fait
l'explosion de la de l'homo sapiens
parce que c'est pas compliqué là c'est
les céréales tirent le diable c'est les
graminées et l'uimm est c'est un animal
domestiqué par les graminées on a parlé
du chat entre 10 et domestiqué par les
graminées aussi les plantes
il les a sous-estimé mais en réalité
toute sa vie a été manipulé par les
plans climats toute sa vie ils ont pris
les océans ils sont allés pourquoi nous
sommes ici au québec parce qu'un gars
qui s'appelait jacques cartier qui est
venu ici chercher quoi jacques cartier
et chercher des épices mais oui il se
trouve que l'on cherchait des gp signant
kabuki arrivé ici chercher des pistes
c'est tout sur la planète les humains
oublier les plantes c'est et ensuite ils
les ont sous-estimé et moi je dis
souvent je suis en train d'écrire un
bouquin là dessus qu'ils appellent le
disciple des plantes parce que il oublie
mais en réalité tout dans toutes les
sociétés où tu vas regarde les grecs
qu'ils adoraient l'olivier le blé avec
le dieu du l'olivier le dieu du blé les
lignes les japonais ont lieu de riz
durée les chinois céleri les africains
c'est le millet et ont pris les plantes
on a toutes nos rituels qui sont
conditionnés par les plantes mais en
même temps on line église parce qu'ils
marchent pas mais les plans ils sont dix
probablement pour investir homo sapiens
il va faire la guerre et la
mondialisation de la végétation c'est
l'humain qui l'a fait
ils n'ont pas posé de bouger ils ont
tous amené le regard las flores ici tu
vas voir là les plantes indigènes et en
a pas tant que ça ces tirs gardant
toutes les îles hawaï quand les gens
arrivent l'aï dit oh mon dieu regarde
c'est une végétation exotique mais non
visitation toutes ces plantes la grande
majorité des plantes qui ont été amenées
par sa peine mais probablement les 10
heures je connais pas beaucoup le monde
végétal ici là mais à plein de choses
que tu vois ici que tu penses que c'est
des plantes indigènes
mais ce ne sont pas l'exemple quand je
donne souvent c'est le pissenlit c'est
le pissenlit viens pas dit si c'est les
européens qui vont mener ici vient des
plaines de l'aude asie le titre a bien
marché que j'arrive à avoir réussi à
bien se développer mon gars
le pis a analysé développer parce qu'il
est très fort il ya des capacités ceux
qui survivent à lui mais ceux qui ont
des capacités d'adaptation les
biologistes ont démontré que le
pissenlit et s'est adaptée même au
passage de la tondeuse le fasse mais ne
brise a lâché passage de tondeuse il
sait fleurir et dire aux enfants
regardez moi comme un champignon
souffler sur dessus et ils savent au
colonisé d'autres territoires
c'est fantastique comment les plantes
nous ont manipulés dans l'histoire c'est
guérin et puis c'est ça on n'est pas
conscient on dit ça on dit qu'on est
très très intelligent mais
l'intelligence c'est pas juste de 18
résoudre des équations mathématiques
sait se débrouiller avec ce qu'on a et
les plans étaient enracinés ils ont ils
ont trouvé des solutions extraordinaire
pour résoudre le problème de ces si
l'itc de cessibilité alors comment les
plantes manipulent les insectes
pollinisateurs un oui dans des ententes
les orchidées mystifie les abeilles
j'avais j'ai vu des images de man sur le
documentaire que je parlais tout à
l'heure de la planète sur netflix
c'est une plante qui laisse rentrer des
abeilles plus les abeilles jouent dans
plantes
oui le la planta se ferme sur les
abeilles sur calais allait durer c'est
oui allégresse plus tu vois la baie à
charge art couverte de repos les bleus a
secoué un peuple à s'en veut placer sur
un autre plan vient de citer reprenant
là qu est la co évolution
c'est à dire que la nature a fignolé des
espèces pour manipuler d'autres et les
coquilles toute beauté 4 quand tu vois
cet écart entre ce qui rend encore plus
malheureux
oui notre traitement de ça à notre
traitement de tout ce qui nous entoure
après des millions des millions d'années
je te manquer par la sélection naturelle
qui tel trait ou telles mutations
aléatoires au fait que l espèce de
prixtel branche oui ça a fonctionné ça a
été un succès pour le fignole exact
exactement les choses au final puis ce
qui fonctionne pas il marre et je ne
sais pas parler d eux qu évolution en
face à un revenant ici jeu tellement
content c'est écrire c'est aussi quand
vous voyez les orchidées les plantes il
récompense les plantes c'est son trait
faire les insectes pollinisateurs
ils sont payés un hectare en pollen
riche en protéines et images puis je te
fais compte que tu viens là tu vas
prendre une partie puis tu as fait condé
l'autre moi je veux perpétuer tout le
monde est content les orchidées c'est
des tricheurs si la population si la
terre était peuplée d'orchidées ce
serait catastrophique pour les insectes
pollinisateurs parce que l'heure qu'il
est il mystifie l'insecte pollinisateur
duty table tu vois les ya des orchidées
qu'on appelle les orchidées abel lafleur
ressemble tellement à la femelle d'une
abeille que quand le mal à rire et à
l'impression que c'est une femme elle a
donc y va pour s'accoupler
n'est ce pas il donne son pollen pitt y
va tous vous voir féconder locales à un
autre mais ne peut rien y en a assez des
arrivées nocibé imagine
imaginez toutes ces concepts locle les
hlm à quel point est-ce que c est ce que
c'est c'est la robe de viande de lady
gaga l'a jamais carnivores pour
l'attraper puis le manger c'est exact
exact ouais c'est ça le devient oui mais
c'est mais c'est ça la beauté de la
nature je pense qu'il faut amener aux
jeunes en leur disant qu'ils regardent
comment des millions d'années comme tu
disais la dc d'erreur de fignolage ont
amené sa salle à tu peux aucune personne
ne sait le temps les orchidées a régné
aux autres leur co évolution c'est que
et vivent dans des environnements oui
des guêpes qui capturent des araignées
c'est les guêpes des fois capture des
araignées les guêpes solitaire les
paralyse les mettre dans le nid
puis un ippon des oeufs en disant aux
enfants mais le frigo est plein là quand
vous viendrez au monde pouvait manger ça
mais ils font juste les paralyser la
pour qu'ils restent vivants mais assez
horrible mais c'est ça et donc les
orchidées ce qu'ils ont fait les
orchidées à renier ceux qui ont pris la
fleur et de sa marine a régné que la gap
solitaire cherche donc à l'agape
solitaire est en chasse voir la fleur
puis parce que c'est une araignée puis
l'essai de l'attraper et pays féconder
comme ça et en rdc stratégie comme ça et
en a en quantité industrielle et c'est
tout ça là comment quand tu le regardes
tu n'as pas le choix comme individu
quand tu t'intéresses en place à de dire
on peut pas saccager ça c'est trop beau
bien n'a pas d'autres planètes
les gars ghsr la sortie en vidéo et
c'est avec une petite fille voir un
cochon cul ouais le genre c'est vraiment
une courte vidéo tu es vraiment été
bonne dit essaie juste de bonnes
affaires parce que tout le monde est
content de la vidéo pris les commandes
du 6 mai pas sexuel préféré la petite
fille on s'en câlisse par exemple le
podcast un club tu vu il revient tout le
temps à chaque vidéo il ya tant de quoi
d'autre sens que j'ai commencé à bloquer
un report un gars qui s'appelle the
world wealth & gold à chaque il revient
à chaque podcast dit et qui de quoi
dans la mare place jean raquin dorion ça
ferait une belle escort lillois commenté
de quoi boucher et aux syndicats matin
pour écouter ça leur apprend à écrire
ces gueux le font toujours des fautes
ouais les jours je me fais insulter par
un groupe qui aimait tant qu' une
syntaxe qu'il n'a pas
[Rires]
[Musique]